If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click Gifts. When you're flying Emirates business class, sampling our range of vintage wines from the largest selection in the skies, you'll see that your vacation isn't really over until your flight is over. Fly Emirates, fly better. Tuesday, CAMH is counting on your support. Together, we can forge a better path for mental health by creating a future where Canadians can get the help they need, when they need it, no matter
如果您想从本节目中获得更多内容，请加入“历史即是一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节的临近，您还可以为您生命中热爱历史的人赠送一整年的会员资格。只需前往 restishistory.com 并点击“礼物”（Gifts）即可。当您乘坐阿联酋航空商务舱，品尝我们从云端最丰富的酒单中精选的陈年葡萄酒时，您会发现，只有当飞行结束时，您的假期才真正结束。选择阿联酋航空，享受更佳飞行体验。周二，CAMH（成瘾与心理健康中心）期待您的支持。通过共同创造一个让加拿大人能在需要时获得所需帮助的未来，无论他们是谁、身在何处，我们都能为心理健康开辟一条更好的道路。
who or where they are. From November 25th to December 2nd, your donation will be doubled. That means every dollar goes twice as far to help build a future where no one's seeking help is left behind. Donate today at camh.ca.ca.g. Tuesday. This episode is sponsored by Hive. History has always been a story of power, who seeks it, who seizes it, and how easily it can all slip away. The Caesars, the Caliphs, the Tsars, they conquered vast swaths of the world, they proclaimed themselves, the favourites of the gods, and yet their empires crumbled away. It is easier to conquer than it is to control. Hive takes a different approach.
从11月25日到12月2日，您的捐款将翻倍。这意味着每一美元都能发挥双倍的作用，帮助建立一个让寻求帮助的人不再被遗忘的未来。请立即在 camh.ca 捐款。周二。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。历史一直是一个关于权力的故事：谁在寻求权力，谁在攫取权力，以及权力又是如何轻易地溜走的。凯撒、哈里发、沙皇，他们征服了广袤的世界，自诩为神的宠儿，然而他们的帝国最终还是土崩瓦解了。征服比控制更容易。Hive 采取了不同的方式。
It puts power where it belongs in your hands. They started with smart thermostats and they've now gone much further. Solar panels, heat pumps, EV chargers, all working together so that you can power your home in your own way. That's genuine empowerment. Checking your phone, seeing the heating's on. The car's charging, and the sun is quietly earning its keep on the roof. Caesar never had to charge his chariots, but I'm sure he would have admired the efficiency. Visit hivehome.com to find out more.
它将权力交还给真正的主人——也就是您手中。他们从智能恒温器起步，如今已走得更远。太阳能电池板、热泵、电动汽车充电器，所有这些设备协同工作，让您能以自己的方式为家庭供电。这才是真正的赋权。查看手机，看到暖气已开启，汽车正在充电，屋顶上的太阳能板正静静地为您创造价值。凯撒从未需要给他的战车充电，但我相信他一定会钦佩这种效率。访问 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。
Subject to survey and suitability, hive compatible with selected technology. Hi everybody, welcome to The Rest is History. For those of you who are new to the show, a little explainer about where we are. For the next two weeks, we'll be looking at one of the most exciting and dramatic moments in modern history, the story of the Nazis in 1939 and 1940. But for those of you who are new to the show, just a little explainer about where we are and how we've got here. So in our previous episodes about the Nazis, we described how this radical right-wing organization spearheaded by Adolf Hitler took power in Germany in 1933 against the background of the humiliation of the First World. war and the collapse of the Weimar Republic. And then Hitler subordinated everything to his vision of making Germany great again and expanding Germany's borders, wiping away the stain of the
需视勘测和适用性而定，Hive 与特定技术兼容。大家好，欢迎收听《历史即是一切》。对于新听众，先简单介绍一下我们目前的进度。接下来的两周，我们将探讨现代史上最激动人心、最戏剧性的时刻之一：1939年和1940年纳粹的故事。但对于新听众，还是先简单说明一下我们身处何处以及是如何走到这一步的。在我们之前关于纳粹的剧集中，我们描述了阿道夫·希特勒领导的这个激进右翼组织，如何在第一次世界大战的屈辱和魏玛共和国崩溃的背景下，于1933年在德国夺取政权。随后，希特勒将一切都服从于他的愿景：让德国再次伟大，扩张德国边界，抹去
Treaty of Versailles, and so on. So previously, we described how he did a deal with Stalin, how he and Stalin dismembered Poland between them. But that, of course, brought Hitler into conflict with the two great Western powers of Britain and France. So in these episodes, We'll be looking at some of the most exciting and dramatic moments in modern history. Hitler survives an attempted coup by his army generals and a bomb plot against him that misses him by minutes. The Fall of France, one of the most awe-inspiring and tragic stories in modern European history. The advent of Winston Churchill, the duel between Hitler and Churchill, the Battle of Britain and the Blitz. And finally, Hitler's decision to turn on Stalin and unleash hell on the Eastern Front, Operation Barbarossa, all of this is coming up.
《凡尔赛条约》带来的耻辱等等。之前我们描述了他如何与斯大林达成协议，以及他与斯大林如何瓜分波兰。但这当然使希特勒与英国和法国这两个西方大国发生了冲突。因此，在这些剧集中，我们将审视现代史上一些最激动人心、最戏剧性的时刻。希特勒在军队将领发动的政变中幸存，以及一场仅差几分钟就炸死他的暗杀阴谋。法国的沦陷，这是现代欧洲史上最令人敬畏且悲惨的故事之一。温斯顿·丘吉尔的崛起，希特勒与丘吉尔之间的决斗，不列颠战役和伦敦大轰炸。最后，希特勒决定背弃斯大林，在东线发动地狱般的“巴巴罗萨行动”，所有这些内容即将呈现。
But we start the series with a truly unforgettable moment, one of the most remarkable impressions that you will ever hear. The continuation of the present state of affairs in the vest is unthinkable. Each day will soon demand greater sacrifices. The national wealth of Europe will be scattered as shellfire. And instead of flourishing towns, there will. will stand only ruins and graves without end. Mr. Churchill and his cronies may interpret these statements as weakness or cowardice, but I need not occupy myself with what they think.
但我们以一个真正令人难忘的时刻开启本系列，这是您所能听到的最非凡的演讲之一。“目前西方的局势是不可想象的。每一天都将很快要求做出更大的牺牲。欧洲的国民财富将化为炮火。繁荣的城镇将不复存在，取而代之的只有废墟和无尽的坟墓。丘吉尔先生和他的亲信们可能会将这些言论解读为软弱或怯懦，但我无需在意他们的想法。”
I make them simply because it goes without saying that I wish to spare my people this suffering, if, however, the opinions of Mr. Churchill. and his followers should prevail. Then we shall fight. Neither force or arms nor the lapse of time will conquer Germany. There will never be another November 1918 in German history. Mr. Churchill may be convinced that Great Britain will win. I do not doubt for a single moment that,
“我之所以这么说，仅仅是因为我不言而喻地希望让我的国民免受这种苦难。然而，如果丘吉尔先生及其追随者的观点占了上风，那么我们将战斗到底。无论是武力、武器还是时间的流逝，都无法征服德国。德国历史上绝不会再有另一个1918年11月。丘吉尔先生可能确信英国会赢。但我从未有片刻怀疑过，
that Germany will be victorious. Destiny will decide who is right. So the unmistakable tones there, Dominic, of Adolf Hitler, and he was addressing the right stag on the 6th October 1939. And as ever with Hitler's speeches, it's a little bit over the top, isn't it? Just a little. Yeah. So the Second World War is a month's old at this point.
德国将会取得胜利。命运将决定谁是对的。”多米尼克，刚才那段毫无疑问是阿道夫·希特勒的声音，他是在1939年10月6日向国会发表的演讲。和希特勒以往的演讲一样，有点夸张，不是吗？确实有一点。是的。所以此时第二次世界大战已经爆发一个月了。
I'm having to catch my breath. I've been quite exhausted by that. Yeah. You don't have his stamina, clearly. No, I don't. I'm not given to rants summoning people to strengthen the sinews of war. Not my vibe at all. So Poland is conquered.
我得喘口气。我被那段演讲搞得筋疲力尽。是的。显然你没有他的耐力。不，我没有。我不习惯那种号召人们加强战争意志的咆哮。那根本不是我的风格。所以波兰已经被征服了。
Hitler's been on a visit to the shattered, smouldering rubble of Warsaw, and he's now come back to Berlin from a Poland that has been brutalized, conquered and occupied. And the Nazi campaign in the East in Poland was one of lightning speed, incredible ferocity, and Hitler has now carved out Lebanon's realm living room for the German people in the East. And now he has to decide what to do about Poland's allies in the West, Britain and France, who had declared war on Germany with the aim of defending Poland, but that aim obviously now lies smouldering a rubble like Warsaw. Yeah, that's right.
希特勒刚刚参观了华沙破碎、冒烟的废墟，现在他从一个被蹂躏、征服和占领的波兰回到了柏林。纳粹在东线波兰的战役以闪电般的速度和令人难以置信的凶猛进行，希特勒现在已经为德国人民在东方开辟了“生存空间”。现在他必须决定如何处理波兰在西方的盟友——英国和法国，他们为了保卫波兰而对德宣战，但那个目标显然现在就像华沙一样，只剩下一片冒烟的废墟。是的，没错。
So he is in that speech. He's actually, despite his warlike tone, he's actually offering peace or pretending to offer peace. And we'll come back to that offer in a few moments. But Tom, while you catch your breath, let's just set the scene, set the scene for listeners who may be new to the rest of his history. put up with previous series. So this is actually our fourth series on the Nazis. We've been tracing the rise and fall of the Third Reich. In the first series, which is back in 2022, we looked at how the Nazis emerged in the chaos after the First World War. They
所以他在那次演讲中，尽管语气好战，但他实际上是在提供和平，或者假装提供和平。我们稍后会回到这个提议。但汤姆，在你喘口气的时候，让我们先为可能刚接触《历史即是一切》的听众梳理一下背景。这是我们关于纳粹的第四个系列。我们一直在追踪第三帝国的兴衰。在2022年的第一个系列中，我们探讨了纳粹如何在第一次世界大战后的混乱中崛起。他们
drew on kind of late Victorian racist, nationalist ideas. The Weimar Republic broke down, democratic experiment broke down, and Hitler was levered into power by conservatives who completely underestimated his radicalism and his ruthlessness. Then we did a second series in 2023, about how he cemented his control over Germany, how he began to move against the Jews, and how he prepared Germany for war. And then our third series, which was last year in 2024, how he swallows Czechoslovakia after appeasement at Munich. His science is packed with Stalin, which will be talking about a fair bit in this series,
利用了维多利亚时代晚期的种族主义和民族主义思想。魏玛共和国崩溃了，民主实验失败了，希特勒被那些完全低估了他的激进和冷酷的保守派推上了权力宝座。然后我们在2023年做了第二个系列，关于他如何巩固对德国的控制，如何开始针对犹太人，以及如何为战争做准备。然后是去年的第三个系列，关于他在慕尼黑协议后的绥靖政策下吞并捷克斯洛伐克。他与斯大林达成的协议，我们在这个系列中会经常提到，
and then he launches the invasion of Poland. And to Hitler's surprise, and he genuinely is shocked and surprised, Britain and France then pile in, on behalf of Poland, and so Europe is facing a second major continental war in 25 years. And Dominic, by invading Poland, Hitler had gambled, hadn't he, that Britain and France wouldn't enter the war, and they do. Yeah. And Hitler, by instinct, is a gambler. He is always likely to roll the dice and see what happens.
然后他发动了对波兰的入侵。令希特勒惊讶的是——他是真的感到震惊和意外——英国和法国随后代表波兰介入，因此欧洲在25年内面临第二次重大洲际战争。多米尼克，通过入侵波兰，希特勒赌的是英法不会参战，但他们确实参战了。是的。希特勒凭直觉就是一个赌徒。他总是倾向于掷骰子，看看会发生什么。
And this is going to be incredibly important for our discussions of what's going to happen in this our fourth series. Exactly, because in this series, when we look at 1939 and 1914, Hitler will launch, effectively, two gambles. One of them is his attack on the West, and the second is he begins to move towards the greatest bet of all, which is his invasion of the Soviet Union. And one thing I will just say before we kick off the narrative,
这对我们讨论本系列即将发生的事情至关重要。没错，因为在这个系列中，当我们审视1939年和1940年时，希特勒实际上将发动两场赌博。其中之一是他对西方的进攻，第二是他开始迈向最大的赌注，即入侵苏联。在开始叙述之前，我想说一件事，
it's interesting that in all the time that we've been recording these series on the Nazis, online, some of the conversation about the Nazis has actually changed a little bit. So you see now in this sort of Anglo-American sort of Twittersphere or whatever, people openly saying, well, the Nazis maybe weren't all that bad. They were pushed into radical measures by the pressures of war. And actually Churchill was just as bad a villain as Hitler. So it's actually really important to stress that during this series, a lot of which will be about kind of military stuff and foreign policy and things,
有趣的是，在我们录制这些关于纳粹的系列节目的这段时间里，网上关于纳粹的讨论实际上发生了一些变化。你现在可以在英美推特圈或其他地方看到，人们公开说，嗯，纳粹也许并没有那么坏。他们是被战争的压力逼迫采取激进措施的。而且实际上丘吉尔和希特勒一样是个恶棍。所以，强调这一点非常重要：在本系列中，尽管大部分内容将涉及军事、外交政策等，
Hitler's radical exterminatory policies are gathering momentum all the time. Specifically two things. One of them is the persecution of the Jews, which has been getting worse since the midnight. 1930s. And the other, which will be an episode in itself in the future series, because I know it's something you've written about, is his forced euthanasia program where he targets the disabled and the mentally ill. And that will end up claiming about a quarter of a million lives, I think. So these are in the background the whole time. You know, Hitler is not a conservative autocrat like other conservative autocrats. There is a kind of exterminatory edge to him
希特勒激进的灭绝政策一直在积聚势头。具体有两件事。一是自1930年代中期以来不断恶化的对犹太人的迫害。另一件，将在未来系列中作为独立的一集，因为我知道你写过相关内容，那就是他针对残疾人和精神病患者的强制安乐死计划。我认为这最终夺走了大约25万人的生命。所以这些背景一直存在。你知道，希特勒不像其他保守派独裁者那样是一个保守的独裁者。他身上有一种灭绝主义的倾向，
all through this story. And that is an important aspect of his attitude to war, isn't it? That war is a natural condition because it enables the strong to prevail over the week. Yeah, completely, completely. And actually that's why he's so comfortable in this. Unlike, let's say, Neville Chamberlain, who will be talking about, Hitler loves all this. He regards this as a natural condition of humanity. So let's get into the story.
贯穿整个故事。这也是他对待战争态度的重要方面，不是吗？即战争是一种自然状态，因为它使强者能够战胜弱者。是的，完全正确。事实上，这就是为什么他对此感到如此自在。与我们将要谈到的内维尔·张伯伦不同，希特勒热爱这一切。他认为这是人类的自然状态。那么，让我们进入故事吧。
Hitler attacked Poland on the 1st of September 1939. The Poles fought heroically with very little help from their so-called allies. But just 16 days later, the Soviet Union, as per their secret pact with Hitler, invaded from the East as well. So Poland ended up being divided between the two. That really is a stab in the back. I mean, completely it is. So the question now is how does Hitler see the war? And as you said, Tom, I mean, I think you're absolutely right.
希特勒于1939年9月1日袭击了波兰。波兰人英勇抵抗，但几乎没有得到他们所谓盟友的任何帮助。但仅仅16天后，苏联按照他们与希特勒的秘密协议，也从东部入侵。因此，波兰最终被两者瓜分。这真的是背后捅了一刀。我的意思是，完全是这样。所以现在的问题是，希特勒是如何看待这场战争的？正如你所说，汤姆，我认为你是完全正确的。
Hitler sees the human condition as one of fighting. In Mein Kampf, in 1925, he had said that basically the life of man is a dreadful struggle for existence. And he had made his warlike ambitions very clear to his high command. So in January 1939, before the war even started, he told his generals that the German heroes of history had embraced brutality, meaning the sword. He said it's time for Germany to stake its claim to the domination of Europe. And then in May 1939, he'd explicitly told them to prepare for war with the West. This is always part of his long-term plan.
希特勒将人类状况视为一种斗争。在1925年的《我的奋斗》中，他曾说，基本上人的生命是一场可怕的生存斗争。他向他的最高指挥部明确表达了他的战争野心。因此，在1939年1月，战争甚至还没开始，他就告诉他的将军们，德国历史上的英雄们拥抱了残酷，即剑。他说，现在是德国为统治欧洲宣示主权的时候了。然后在1939年5月，他明确告诉他们要为与西方的战争做准备。这始终是他长期计划的一部分。
England is our enemy and the showdown with England. is a matter of life and death. As we'll see, Hitler has a very conflicted attitude to what he calls England. On the one hand, he admires it because as an empire, as Anglo-Saxon cousins, but on the other, he does think that at the end of the day, England is kind of going to be,
“英国是我们的敌人，与英国的决战是生死攸关的问题。”正如我们将看到的，希特勒对他所谓的“英国”有着非常矛盾的态度。一方面，他钦佩它，因为它是一个帝国，作为盎格鲁-撒克逊表亲，但另一方面，他确实认为，归根结底，英国
or England or the United States will be the kind of final boss, as it were, if it was a video game, that Germany will have to overcome for mastery of the world. If only, he'd married Unity Mitford. If only, yeah. It's depressing to get her on the show
或者美国将是最终的“大BOSS”，如果这是一款电子游戏的话，德国必须克服它才能掌握世界。要是他娶了尤妮蒂·米特福德就好了。要是就好了。这么快就在节目中提到她真是令人沮丧，因为你知道她不是我最喜欢的人。总之，问题是希特勒并不认为这场与英国的决战会很快发生。他的将军们告诉他，德国空军要到1942年才能准备好，海军要到1943年。而他的陆军（国防军）没有针对西方战争的计划。所以实际上，当他袭击波兰时，直到最后一刻，他都在试图与英国人达成协议，让他们置身事外。他实际上给内维尔·张伯伦发了一条信息，说：“如果你给我自由，给我一点波兰，我就保证大英帝国的边界。”
so soon, because you know she's not my favorite person. Anyway, the thing is Hitler doesn't think this showdown with England is going to happen anytime soon. His generals have told him that the Luftwaffe will not be ready till 1942 and the fleet until 1943. And the Vermak, his army, don't have a plan for a war in the West. So actually, when he attacks Poland, right up to the last minute, he's trying to make a deal with the British to keep them out of it. And he says, effectively sends a message to Chamberlain, Neville Chamberlain, to say, I will guarantee the borders of the British Empire if you give me a free hand and give me a little bit of Poland.
当张伯伦拒绝时，他真的非常惊讶，因为他曾称张伯伦为“小虫子”，认为他永远不会战斗，这让他大吃一惊。低估了英国人的勇气。他低估了英国人的勇气。或者他真的低估了吗？因为战争已经持续了一个月，而盟军实际上什么也没做。一个显而易见的原因是，他们对“伟大战争”的经历——那些巨大的伤亡——感到如此创伤，例如，法国在第一次世界大战中损失了超过一百万人，以至于他们在1939年现在真的没有那种强行解决问题的战争精神。所以，正如我们在上一个系列中描述的那样，法军在边境集结。他们实际上在德国最西部的萨尔地区进入了几天。他们的兵力是德国人的五倍。然后他们就说，嗯，你知道，我们看了一下，现在我们要回去了。所以德国人有这种防御工事，
And he's really, really astonished when Chamberlain says no, because he had described Chamberlain as a little worm and thought that he would never fight and has really taken her back. Underestimated British pluck. He had underestimated British pluck. Or had he? Because the war has now been going on for a month and the Allies really have done nothing. And one obvious reason for this is that they are so traumatised by the experience of the Great
齐格菲防线，不是吗？但那里，我的意思是，它根本没有被重兵把守。法国人走到它面前。詹姆斯·霍兰德（我兄弟）在《西线战争：1939-1941年德国崛起》一书中有一个极好的描述。他引用了一名法国士兵走到齐格菲防线前的经历。他们被一挺自动武器射击。面对这挺自动武器，法国人随后撤退了。我兄弟写道：“一代人之前，法国步兵在炮火下冲锋，进入机枪和步枪的猛烈风暴中。现在，整个推进都被一挺武器阻挡了。”我发现这真的很震撼，因为他是对的。我的意思是，我们在关于第一次世界大战初期几个月的系列节目中谈到过这一点。成千上万的法国士兵被德国火力扫射。而现在，他们好像失去了
war by the massive casualties, the French, for example, had lost more than a million men in the First World War, that they don't really have the sort of warlike spirit to force the issue now in 1939. So, as we described in the last series, the French troops massed on their borders. They actually went into the Tsarland in the far west of Germany for a few days. They outnumbered the Germans five to one. And then they sort of said, well, you know, we've had a little look around and we'll go back now. So the Germans have this kind of fortified. line, don't they? The Siegfried line. But there are, I mean, it's really not heavily occupied at all. And the French kind of go up to it. And an excellent description in a book by James
他们的胆量，我想。嗯，我认为正是因为那件事发生了。他们不想让它再次发生。他们知道代价，对吧？他们知道那是一个可怕的错误，1914年的边境战役什么的，当穿着19世纪制服的法国人向机枪推进并被扫射时，他们不想让它再次发生。事实上，我认为盟军领导人，即张伯伦和法国总理达拉第，他们最终希望德国人能恢复理智并除掉希特勒，希望经济压力能起到作用，并且会有一个长期的僵局，最终德国人会感到厌倦，或者他们会意识到希特勒
Holland, my brother, the war in the West, Germany ascendant 1939 to 1941. And he quotes a French soldier going up to the Siegfried line. And they're fired at by a single automatic weapon. And faced by this single automatic weapon, the French then retreat. And my brother, other rights. A generation earlier, French Pauilu had advanced David Grand torn up by shellfire into withering storms of machine gun and rifle fire. Now entire advances were being held up by a single weapon. And I found that really striking because he's right. I mean, we were talking about this in the series that we did on the early months of the First World War. I mean, thousands upon thousands of French soldiers being moaned down by German fire. And now it's like they've lost
是一个坏蛋，他们会除掉他。但你认为这是否也因为纳粹宣传的效力？因为实际上，这对法国人来说是入侵的绝佳机会，因为所有的德国军队都在波兰。所以他们完全可以冲破齐格菲防线。但德国人在暗示纳粹军队不可战胜方面表现得非常出色。有一个故事说，一位法国空军首长被邀请视察德国空军总部和各个机场。他们从一个机场飞到另一个机场。
their cahones, I guess. Well, I think it's precisely because that happened. They don't want that to happen again. They know the cost, right? And they know that was a terrible mistake, the Battle of the Frontiers in 1914 or whatever, when Frenchmen in kind of 19th century uniforms advanced towards the machine guns and were mowed down, they don't want that to happen again. And actually, I think the allied leaders, so Chamberlain and Deladier, who is the French prime minister, they are ultimately hoping that the Germans will come to their senses and get rid of Hitler, that economic pressure will do the job, and that there'll be a long standoff and eventually the Germans will get bored or they'll realize that Hitler
当法国首长被运送时，德国人正忙着把飞机从一个机场转移到另一个机场，看起来德国空军实际上比它本身要大得多。但我认为这一定是其中的一部分，这种感觉是他们吞下了戈培尔的宣传，认为纳粹是钢铁般的、不可战胜的。你知道，没有击败他们的希望。而事实上，事实恰恰相反。这是法国人击溃德国在西方防御的机会。
is a bad, you know, a baden and they'll get rid of him. But do you think it's also because of the kind of the potency of Nazi propaganda? Because actually, this was the perfect opportunity for the French to invade because all the German forces are away in Poland. So they absolutely could have stormed the Siegfried line. But the Germans have been brilliant at suggesting that the Nazi forces are invincible. There's some story of a, of a, of a, of a, you know, a French air chief being invited to inspect the headquarters of the Luftwaffe and the kind of various aerodromes. And they go from aerodrome to aerodrome.
但这是一个他们完全错过的机会。这就是为什么，你知道，这种惯性感是人们称之为“无聊战争”，或者最著名地称之为“假战争”的原因。你知道，这是一场我们基本上什么都不做的战争。而且我认为有一种明确的感觉，随着1939年的秋天变成39-40年的冬天，西方的士气正在下滑。所以“大众观察”（Mass Observation）——这就像是1930年代末在英国进行的一种巨大的原型焦点小组——报告说，我引用：“国内有一种强烈的感受，认为这场可悲的
And while the French chief is being transported, the Germans are busy moving the planes from one aerdrome to another so that it looks as though the Luftwaffe is actually much larger than it is. But I think that must be part of it, this sense that they've swallowed Gerbil's propaganda, that the Nazis are kind of steel-tipped, invincible. You know, there's no prospect of defeating them. Whereas in fact, the opposite is the truth. This was the chance for the French to kind of overwhelm the German defences in the West.
战争并没有进行下去。”我们可以怀疑希特勒赢得了这场战争的第一轮。他能够给本国人民一个巨大的成功故事：波兰。我们一无所有。我们什么也没做。而且在所有人中，法国存在主义者让-保罗·萨特被征召入伍。11月，他在日记中写道：“起初所有人都跃跃欲试，但现在他们正死于无聊。战争机器在空转。”他讲了一个故事
But it's a chance they completely miss. And that's why, you know, the sense of inertia is why people call it the Boer War, or they call it most famously the phony war. You know, it's a war in which we're basically doing nothing. And there's a definite sense, I think, that as the autumn of 1939 becomes the winter of 39-40, morale in the West is sort of sagging. So mass observation, which was like this sort of giant proto-focused group conducted in the late 1930s in Britain, reports, and I quote, a strong feeling in the country that this wretched
关于一个中士对他说：“嗯，我认为这，你知道，这一切都会解决的。一切都会安排好的。英国会退缩。”换句话说，法国人认为，我们实际上是被英国人拖进来的，他们想对抗希特勒。也许，你知道，会有某种协议，我们都可以回家。而这基本上就是我们想要的。所以那种“荣耀”的梦想在法军阵线中并没有真正体现出来。第一次世界大战抹去了很多战争热情和战斗精神之类的东西。而且出于完全可以理解的原因，我不认为这有什么奇怪的。所以这一切把主动权留给了希特勒。事实上，现在有一个点，
war is not going on with. We can suspect that Hitler has won news round one in this war. He's been able to give his own people a tremendous success story, Poland. We've got nothing. We've done nothing. And of all people, Jean-Paul Sartre, the French existentialist, was drafted into the French French army. And in November, he wrote in his diary, all the men were raring to go at the outset, but now they're dying of boredom. The war machine is running in neutral. And he tells a story
如果他愿意，他可以真正努力向英法提供协议。所以外交部的一位高级公务员，一个叫埃里希·冯·魏茨泽克的人，告诉他：“我认为如果你现在竭尽全力向伦敦和巴黎示好，他们有五分之一的机会接受。”这就是我们开头提到的演讲的背景。希特勒基本上说：“看，波兰完了。它永远不会被恢复。它现在在我们和俄国人之间被永久瓜分了。”他说：“这是我对英国和法国人民的呼吁。你们是被所谓的‘犹太国际资本主义和新闻业’拖进来的。”
about a sergeant who said to him, well, I think this is, you know, this is all going to be sorted. It's all going to be arranged. England will climb down. In other words, the French think, we've actually been dragged into this really by the British, who wanted to stand up to Hitler. And maybe, you know, we can, it'll be some deal and we can all go home. And that's basically what we want. So kind of dreams of la gloat not really manifest in the French lines. The First World War has wiped away a lot of the war enthusiasm and the sort of fighting spirits and whatnot. And for completely understandable reasons, I don't think there's anything weird about that. So all of this leaves Hitler with the initiative. And actually, there is a point now where
他与之联系起来的人当然是温斯顿·丘吉尔，一位前记者，你知道，资本主义的热情捍卫者，一个有很多犹太联系和朋友的人。希特勒说：“为什么我们不举行另一次慕尼黑会议来解决欧洲的安全问题？”当然，张伯伦拒绝了这一点。他总是会拒绝的。是的，当然，一朝被蛇咬，十年怕井绳。是的，下议院永远不会允许他接受。如果英法接受了，会发生什么？我认为这只会推迟不可避免的事情，因为正如我们所见，希特勒已经向他的将军们明确表示。他认为西方的战争迟早是不可避免的。无论如何，希特勒有点知道他们总是会拒绝的。而且他实际上急于在西方进行战争，部分原因是，正如你所说，他是一个赌徒，这是他自我形象的重要组成部分。他痴迷于他所看到的某种“大胆打击”，你知道，决定性的突击，所有那种事情。
he could, if he was so minded, he could make a real effort to offer the British and the French deal. So the senior civil servant at the foreign office, who's a guy called Erzvon, Weissiker, tells him, I reckon there's a one in five chance that if you go out of your way now to make overtures to London and to Paris, that they will accept. So this is the context for the speech that we began with. And Hitler basically says, look, Poland is finished. It's never going to be brought back. It's divided permanently now between us and the Russians. He says, this is my appeal to the people of Britain and France. You have been dragged into this by, quote, Jewish international capitalism and journalism.
他认为让步和妥协是软弱。他把这与戴着硬领、带着雨伞的民主选举产生的领导人联系在一起。那根本不是他的风格。一点也不是他的风格。但还有其他很好的理由让他如此匆忙。第一，正如我们在之前的系列中谈到的，希特勒是一个巨大的疑病症患者，
And the person that he associates with that is Winston Churchill, of course, a former journalist and, you know, an enthusiastic defender of capitalism and a man with a lot of Jewish contacts and friends. And Hitler says, why don't we have another Munich and other conference to settle Europe's security? Now, of course, Chamberlain rejects this. He was always going to reject it. Yeah, of course, once bitten, twice I. Yeah, and the House of Commons would never have allowed him to accept it. Had Britain and France accepted, what would have happened, I think it would only have delayed the inevitable, because as we've seen, Hitler has made it very clear to his generals. He thinks war in the West is inevitable one day. Anyway, Hitler kind of knows they're always going to reject it. And he's actually in a hurry to get on with the war in the West, partly because, as you said, he is a gambler, and that's an important part of his self-image. He's obsessed with what he sees as the kind of the bold strike, you know, the decisive thrift.
他知道他的父母死得很早。他认为他可能也会早死。他痴迷于自己的健康，他正在喝，他正在狂饮，大量的枪支清洁油，试图让自己好起来。这不聪明，不是吗？对于任何可能想效仿阿道夫·希特勒的人来说。那是一个很好的医疗建议。不要喝枪支清洁油。
trust, all of that kind of thing. And he thinks concession and compromise are weakness. And he associates that with democratically elected leaders in kind of stiff collars and carrying umbrellas. And that's not his vibe at all. Not his vibe in the slightest. But there are also other good reasons why he'd be in such a hurry. Number one, as we've talked about in previous series, Hitler is a massive hypochondriac who
或者入侵波兰。或者入侵波兰，对。他还知道德国的经济状况不好。所以基本上，他所谓的“经济奇迹”是建立在沙子上的。他有一种对更多原材料、更多领土、资源和食物的啃噬般的需要。没有扩张，德国经济就会崩溃。我的意思是，这是一个非常重要的点，不是吗？在这一点上，德国经济以及德国武装部队确实有一种“波特金”式的虚假繁荣。
knows that his parents died young. And he thinks that he might die young as well. and he is obsessed with his health and he is drinking, his necking, gigantic quantities of gun cleaning oil in an attempt to sort himself out. And that's not wise, is it? Just for anyone listening who might be tempted to emulate Adolf Hitler. A bit of medical advice there, that's nice. Don't drink gun cleaning oil.
它们并不像法国或英国人倾向于认为的那样令人印象深刻。经济同样可能处于可怕的状态，这意味着本质上，如果它要稳定下来，唯一的办法就是从被征服的领土上掠夺财富和原材料。没错。所以他必须不断消耗橡胶、石油、所有这些东西，以及食物和脂肪。还有铁矿石，这也将很重要，不是吗？当然，希特勒也知道盟军希望进行一场长期战争。你知道，他们上次打了一场长期战争，这就是他们获胜的方式。他知道如果他们进行长期战争，他们将能够提高他们的重整军备计划。他们将从他们的殖民地获得支持和资源，也许从长远来看从美国获得支持。
Or invade Poland. Or invade Poland, right. He also knows that Germany's economy is not in a good shape. So basically, his so-called economic miracle is built on sand. he has this sort of gnawing need for more raw materials and more territory and resources and food. And without expansion, the German economy will just collapse. I mean, this is a really important point to emphasise, isn't it? That there is at this point a real Potemkin quality about the German economy and also about the German armed forces.
而那是他最不想要的。他想迅速击垮他们。还有一个具体的事实是，希特勒知道英国的战略将与“伟大战争”中一样，即实施封锁。而封锁对一个已经摇摇欲坠的经济的影响将是致命的。而这实际上就是1918年使德国屈服的原因。这大概就是他绝对想避免的。是的，德国人民知道这一点。我的意思是，别忘了，德国人民认为他们并没有在1918年的战场上输掉战争。
They are not as impressive as people in France or Britain tend to assume. And the economy likewise is potentially in a terrible state, which means essentially that if it is going to be stabilized, the only way to do that is to plunder wealth and raw materials from conquered territories. Exactly. So he's got to keep consuming kind of rubber and oil and all of these kinds of things and food and fats. And iron ore, which will also be important, won't it? And of course, Hitler also knows the Allies are hoping for a long war. You know, they had a long war last time and that's how they won. He knows that if they have a long war, they will be able to up their rearmament programs. They'll get support and resources from their colonies and from the United States maybe in the long run.
你知道，他们可能对此是错的，但他们就是这么认为的。他们认为他们在国内的后方输掉了战争，而这就是他们想要避免的。所以希特勒从波兰回到柏林的当天，他就对他的指挥官们说：“我希望你们现在就制定在西方进攻的计划。”他说：“时间对我们不利。我们必须继续。”
And that's the last thing he wants. He wants to knock them out quickly. And is it also the specific fact that Hitler knows that Britain's strategy will be the same as in the Great War, which is to impose a blockade. And the impact of a blockade on an already tottering economy will be lethal. and that effectively is what had brought Germany to its knees in 1918. That presumably is absolutely what he wants to avoid. Yeah, and the German people know this. I mean, don't forget, the German people think they didn't lose the war on the battlefield in 1918.
他说：“事情是这样的。这里真正的威胁是英国人。法国人没用。”希特勒从不看重法国人。他说：“如果我们先击垮法国人，英国人就不会在大陆上有立足点。”所以为了让英国屈服，这是一个直接引语，“我们必须摧毁法国。”仅仅强调他所担心的英国的不是它的军队，而是它的舰队以及它扼杀德国经济的能力。但他认为，如果你拒绝给英国人在欧洲大陆上的任何立足点，那么他们就不会继续下去。他的将军们说：“嗯，你什么时候想做？”希特勒说：“我想现在就做。我想在今年秋天，1939年的秋天做。”他们明显感到震惊。他们惊呆了。即使是赫尔曼·戈林，你知道，那个“人山”，希特勒的顶级亲信。他，血色从他那吸血鬼般的面孔上褪去。他不敢相信。他是空军司令，不是吗？他知道空军还没有
You know, they might be wrong about that, but that's what they think. They think they lost it at home on the home front, and that's what they want to avoid. So the very day that Hitler came back to Berlin from Poland, he said to his commanders, I want you to draw up plans for an attack in the West now. He said, time works against us. We have to continue. and he said, here's the thing. The real threat here are the British. The French are useless. Hitler never rates the French. He said, if we knock the French out first, the British will not have a
为这样的战役做好准备，大概将军们也觉得国防军还没有为这样的战役做好准备。没错。所以当张伯伦说，你知道，对和平协议说“不”时，希特勒说：“太好了，让我们加强这次行动的计划。”他告诉戈培尔：“从某种意义上说，张伯伦说‘不’是个好消息。我很高兴我们可以针对英国。我们一定会赢。我们1918年失败的唯一原因是由于被背叛了。”我的意思是，这对希特勒来说是愚蠢的。这是一个很好的例子，说明他的意识形态如何使他盲目于政治、军事、经济现实。他说：“英国人将不得不通过艰难的方式学习。”
foothold on the continent. So to bring England to its knees, this is a direct quote, we must destroy France. And just to emphasise what he is nervous about with Britain isn't its army, but its fleet and its ability to throttle Germany's economy. But he thinks that if you deny the British any foothold on the European mainland, then they won't carry on. His generals say, well, when would you like to do it? Hitler says, I want to do it now. I want to do it this autumn in the autumn of 1939. And they are visibly shocked. They are stunned. Even Herman Guring, you know, Man Mountain, Hitler, top Hitler crony. He kind of the blood drains from his vampiric features. He can't believe that. He's a commander of the Air Force, isn't he? And he knows that the Air Force isn't
他向他的总司令，我们将谈论很多的那个人，名叫瓦尔特·冯·布劳希奇，也表达了类似的观点。现在，布劳希奇来自一个普鲁士军事家庭。他在爱国服务和职责的传统中长大。他实际上是一个很好的军队例子，因为布劳希奇总是非常谨慎。他不想进入奥地利进行“德奥合并”。
ready for such a campaign, and presumably the generals feel that the Wehrmacht isn't ready for such a campaign either. Exactly. So when Chamberlain says, you know, no, no to a peace deal, Hitler says, great, let's step up the plans for this operation. He says to Goebbels, this is good news in a way that Chamberlain has said, no, I'm glad we can go for England. We will definitely win. The only reason we lost in 1918 is because we were betrayed. I mean, this is foolish from Hitler. This is the kind of a really good example of how his ideology he blinds him to political, military, economic realities. And he says, the English will have to learn the hard way.
他不想进入捷克斯洛伐克。他总是对这些事情非常紧张，认为它们会引发一场战争，一场德国会输掉的世界战争。但他实际上欠希特勒的债。希特勒借给了他数万帝国马克，帮助布劳希奇与妻子离婚并娶了他的情妇。所以他完全被希特勒所俘获，并且非常害怕他。克肖，希特勒的传记作者，称他为，我引用，“没骨气的”。
And he makes a similar point to his commander-in-chief, his man will be talking about a fair bit, who is called Valta von Browkich. Now, Browkich is from a Prussian military family. He's been raised in the sort of tradition of patriotic service and duty and whatnot. He's a really good example, actually, of the army, because Browcich was always very cautious. He didn't want to go into Austria in the Anschlis.
布劳希奇确实没骨气。尽管是陆军首脑，他却是一个巨大的软弱男人。即使他对此感到焦虑，希特勒也对他说：“不，我希望你尽快对付英国人。英国人是那种只有在被打败后才会和你谈话的人。你必须先打败他们。”这次袭击将被命名为“黄色方案”（Fall Gelb），我希望它在11月12日发生。在接下来的几周里，希特勒真的让自己兴奋起来。他非常兴奋，只有他能那样。他召集了他所有的纳粹党官员。他说：“我们将在几周内进攻。”
He didn't want to go into Czechoslovakia. He was always very nervous of these things, thought they would provoke a war, a world war, that Germany would lose. But he is literally in debt to Hitler. Hitler has lent him tens of thousands of Reichs Marx to help Broucich divorce his wife and marry his mistress. So he's completely enthralled to Hitler and he's terrified of him. In Kershaw, Hitler's biographer, calls him, and I quote, spineless.
“我们将轰炸英国和法国的城市。我的梦想，”他说，“是重建神圣罗马帝国。所以让我们拿回瑞士。让我们拿回比利时。还有荷兰的一点点。”是的，让我们在西方让德国再次伟大。他谈论这个越多，这就是，你知道，希特勒的特点之一。他谈论得越多，他就越沉醉于自己的修辞。所以到了11月6日，当他与戈培尔交谈时，他说：“英国的力量现在仅仅是一个神话。它不再是一个现实了。这更说明它必须被粉碎。”我总觉得他们就像青少年，在派对前变得越来越轻浮。只是想问，这也是我兄弟在他的书中提出的一个观点，
And Browkich is spineless. Despite being the head of the army, he is a kind of massive weakling of a man. And even though he's anxious about this, Hitler says to him, no, I want you to get at the British as quickly as possible. The British are the kind of people that will only talk to you once they've been beaten. You have to beat them first. And the attack will be called Falgelp, Case Yellow, and I want it to happen on the 12th of. November. And in the next few weeks, Hitler is really working himself up. He's very excited in the way only he can be. He gathers all his Nazi party officials. He says, we're going to be attacking
实际上，自腓特烈大帝时代以来，普鲁士乃至德国在洲际战争中的战略一直就是计划进行快速攻击，因为这是德国人可能取得胜利的唯一途径。他们在19世纪对丹麦、对法国都这样做过。当然，在1914年，他们计划的战略完全一样，你知道，快速攻击，横扫比利时，降临巴黎。我的意思是，这就是德国战略一直以来的样子。所以在这个程度上，希特勒并没有做一些真正不寻常的事情。不，我认为他们显然有两个大问题，贯穿整个德国历史。
within weeks. We're going to bomb the cities of Britain and France. My dream, he says, is to recreate the Holy Roman Empire. So let's get Switzerland back. Let's get Belgium back. It's a bit of Holland. Yeah, let's make Germany great again in the West. And the more he talks about this, this is, you know, one of the things with Hitler. The more he talks, the more he gets drunk on his own rhetoric. So by the 6th of November, when he talks to Goebbels, he says, England's power is now simply a myth. It's not a reality any longer. All the more reason why it must be smashed. They're like teenagers, I always think, getting more and more giddy before a party or something. Just to ask, and this is a point my brother makes in his book, there is
第一，他们很容易被敌人包围，因为德国的地理位置，第二，也因为它的地理位置，它通往海洋的出口有限，所以它的贸易很容易被封锁等扼杀。这两件事显然从长远来看在第一次世界大战中对德国不利。而且，我的意思是，你可以争辩说他的战略愿景在一定程度上是正确的。因为，我的意思是，他确实击败了法国。问题是，我们将谈论的这个系列中贯穿希特勒的所有大问题，他的大愚蠢，其实有点像拿破仑，他并没有
actually a sense in which it has ever since the time of Frederick the Great been Prussian and then German strategy in a continental war to kind of plan for rapid attacks because it's the only way that the Germans can possibly have a victory. And they've done it in the 90th century against Denmark, against France. And of course, in 1914, it was exactly the same strategy that they were planning, you know, the rapid attack, the sweep through Belgium, are descending on Paris. I mean, this is what German strategy has always been about. So to that extent, Hitler isn't really doing something that unusual. No, and I think they have two big problems, obviously, that run right through German history.
曾经有一种感觉，这一切将如何结束。因为如果英国人不同意达成协议，那么对他来说，这一切怎么能以好的方式结束呢？因为英国人有他们的帝国，他们有他们的舰队，正如我们将看到的，他们实际上是不可征服的。所以，你知道，你带着这个去哪里？那是他的问题。所以这对将军们来说是一种焦虑，但我猜这并不是，你知道，在短期内，他们会认识到要击败法国，他们确实需要进攻。但我猜是时机问题，而不是整体战略本身。
Number one, they're very easily encircled by enemies, so because of Germany's geographical location, and number two, also because of its geographical location, it has limited outlets to the sea, so its trade can very easily be choked off by blockades and so on. And both of those things obviously worked against Germany in the long run in the First World War. And, I mean, you can argue his strategic vision up to a point is right. because, I mean, he does beat France. The problem is, the great problem which will run through all this series that we talk about for Hitler, his great folly, a tiny bit like Napoleon, actually, he doesn't
是的，我认为是时机问题。你知道，这些人通常是在第一次世界大战的战壕里服役，在东线战斗过的人。所以失去第一次世界大战的经历是他们一生中最具决定性的时刻。所以，当然，他们会担心在西方再次掷骰子。所以，你知道，有一个叫里特·冯·莱布的陆军上将，他在日记中写道：“你知道，我不敢相信我们又要穿过荷兰和比利时了。你知道，它们是中立国。我们再次……”之前效果很好。
ever have a sense of how this will end. Because if the British don't agree to do a deal, then how does it ever end for him in a good way? Because the British have their empire, they have their fleet, as we'll see, they're effectively unconquerable. So, you know, where do you go with this? That's his problem. And so that's an anxiety for the generals, but also I guess it's not so much, you know, in the kind of the short term, they would recognize that to certainly knock out France, they do need to go on the attack. But I'm guessing it's the timing that's the issue rather than the kind of overall strategy itself.
曾经对这一切将如何结束有过预感吗？因为如果英国人不同意达成协议，那么对他来说，这一切怎么可能有一个好的结局呢？因为英国人拥有他们的帝国，拥有他们的舰队，正如我们将要看到的那样，他们实际上是不可征服的。所以，你知道，你还能怎么办呢？这就是他的难题。因此，这对将军们来说是一种焦虑，但我猜在短期内，他们并不太担心这一点，他们会认识到，要彻底击垮法国，他们确实需要发动进攻。但我猜问题在于时机，而不是整体战略本身。
Yeah, I think it's the timing. It's the, you know, these are people often who served in the trenches in the First World War, who fought on the Eastern Front. So the experience of losing the First World War. is the single most formative moment of their lives. And so, of course, they're going to be anxious about throwing the dice yet again in the West. So, you know, there's a guy called Colonel General Ritter von Lieb, who writes in his diary. You know, I can't believe we're going to go through Holland and Belgium again. You know, they're neutral countries. We're once again. Worked out so well before.
是的，我认为是时机问题。你知道，这些人通常是在第一次世界大战的战壕中服役，在东线作战过的人。所以，输掉第一次世界大战的经历，是他们一生中最具决定性的时刻。因此，他们当然会担心再次在西线孤注一掷。所以，你知道，有一个叫里特·冯·勒布的陆军大将，他在日记中写道。你知道，我不敢相信我们又要穿过荷兰和比利时了。你知道，他们是中立国。我们又要重蹈覆辙了。上次这样做效果可真好。
Yeah, we're going to make the same mistake. And he writes in his diary, the whole world will turn on Germany, you know, if we do this. And this is the big threat to Hitler's regime. The threat to Hitler's regime for all that he's gone on about, of course, the Jews, communists, social democrats, trade unionists, whatever. The real threat has always been from the army, from the kind of nationalist, conservative wing of German politics. That's why the night of the long knives, when he purged his own movement, he was basically sucking up to the army because he was worried about alienating them. And so with the army, there's a kind of also class element, isn't there? That they're kind of Prussian aristocrats and they look down on Hitler.
是的，我们要犯同样的错误。他在日记中写道，如果我们这样做，全世界都会反对德国。这对希特勒的政权构成了巨大的威胁。尽管希特勒一直喋喋不休地谈论犹太人、共产党人、社会民主党人、工会成员等等，但对他政权的真正威胁始终来自军队，来自德国政坛中那种民族主义、保守派的势力。这就是为什么在“长刀之夜”，当他清洗自己的运动时，他实际上是在讨好军队，因为他担心疏远他们。所以对于军队来说，也存在一种阶级因素，不是吗？他们是普鲁士贵族，看不起希特勒。
Who is this Austrian corporal? You know, who is he to boss us around? And even before the outbreak of the Second World War, so really by the summer of 1938, there are quite a few groups of people in kind of the army or in political establishment circles who think Hitler is bonkers and his leading Germany to disaster. They're nationalists.
这个奥地利下士是谁？你知道，他算什么东西，也配对我们指手画脚？甚至在第二次世界大战爆发之前，也就是到1938年夏天，军队或政治建制派圈子里已经有不少人认为希特勒是个疯子，正在把德国引向灾难。他们是民族主义者。
So they don't necessarily disagree with his aims, but they just think, come on, this is. so reckless and so counterproductive. Again, they are not wrong. So there's a group at the Foreign Office. There's a group at the Abwehr, which is German intelligence, working for Admiral Canaris. There is a group of nationalist politicians around a guy called Carl Gerdler, who wants being the Reich Price Commissioner. And in particular, there's a group of army officers who are loyal to the former Army Chief of Staff Ludwig Beck, who we talked about in our last series, we talked about how Beck resigned in 1938
所以他们不一定不同意他的目标，只是觉得，拜托，这太鲁莽了，而且适得其反。再说一次，他们并没有错。外交部有一个小组。阿勃维尔（Abwehr，德国军事情报局）有一个小组，为卡纳里斯海军上将工作。还有一个由卡尔·格德勒（Carl Goerdeler）领导的民族主义政治家小组，他曾任帝国价格监督专员。特别值得一提的是，还有一群忠于前陆军总参谋长路德维希·贝克（Ludwig Beck）的陆军军官，我们在上一系列节目中谈到过他，谈到过贝克是如何在1938年辞职的。
after failing to get the other generals to turn on Hitler. And actually, there were plans for a coup. At the end of 1938, which were abandoned because Britain and France appeased Hitler in Munich. And so the generals thought, well, this isn't the time. And so they dropped their scheme. They're still kind of in touch with each other. So they're still kind of informally chatting. You know, this bloke's a bit bonkers, isn't he?
在未能说服其他将军反对希特勒之后。事实上，1938年底曾有过政变计划，但因为英国和法国在慕尼黑对希特勒采取了绥靖政策而作罢。将军们认为，现在不是时候。于是他们放弃了计划。他们之间仍然保持着联系，私下里还在闲聊。你知道，这家伙有点疯，不是吗？
you know, maybe we'll have to get rid of him. And amazingly, and this will probably surprise a lot of listeners, the men at the top of the German army are in on this. So Valtar von Broucich, who I described, the guy is in debt to Hitler, and his chief of staff, who is a sort of clipped, bespectacled staff officer called France Haldor, they have been privately talking about getting rid of Hitler for months and months. And now that he says he wants to attack the West, They have a secret meeting on the 14th of October. And Halder says to Browkitsch, look, we've got three options here. Number one, we go along with Hitler and we attack the West.
你知道，也许我们得除掉他。令人惊讶的是，这可能会让很多听众感到意外，德国军队的高层也参与其中。我之前描述过的瓦尔特·冯·布劳希奇（Walther von Brauchitsch），这家伙欠了希特勒的人情，还有他的参谋长，一个叫弗朗茨·哈尔德（Franz Halder）的刻板、戴眼镜的参谋军官，他们私下里已经讨论了几个月要除掉希特勒。现在希特勒说他想进攻西方，他们在10月14日举行了一次秘密会议。哈尔德对布劳希奇说，看，我们有三个选择。第一，我们顺从希特勒，进攻西方。
Number two, we somehow persuade him to wait and to call it off. Or number three, we have to make fundamental changes. And what does fundamental changes mean? It probably means we're going to have to declare Hitler mad, put him under arrest, and launch a coup in Berlin. And Browcich, because he is, as Ian Kershaw says, spineless, he's never going to go for the third option. He says, look, I mean, I think we're going to just have to try and persuade him. Let's change his mind.
第二，我们设法说服他等待并取消计划。或者第三，我们必须做出根本性的改变。什么是根本性的改变？这可能意味着我们必须宣布希特勒疯了，将他逮捕，并在柏林发动政变。而布劳希奇，正如伊恩·克肖（Ian Kershaw）所说，是个没骨气的人，他永远不会选择第三种方案。他说，看，我的意思是，我想我们只能试着说服他。让我们改变他的想法。
So that's what Browkich wants to do. Now, his deputy, Haldor, is not convinced by this. He thinks Hitler is unpersuadable. And by early November, 1939, Haldor, the chief of staff of the army, has made contact with other groups of plotters. They have a scheme. They will kill Hitler. they will arrest the leaders of the other Nazi bigwigs and they'll take Germany over
这就是布劳希奇想做的。现在，他的副手哈尔德并不相信这一点。他认为希特勒是无法被说服的。到1939年11月初，陆军参谋长哈尔德已经与其他阴谋集团取得了联系。他们有一个计划。他们要杀死希特勒，逮捕其他纳粹高官，接管德国。
and they will negotiate peace with the allies. Haldor actually sends an intermediary to some of the other leading generals, Fedor von Bok, Gert von Rundstedt, generals who will be hearing a lot about in this series. And these generals say, yeah, I don't like the thought of attacking in the West doing this replay of 1914 either.
然后与盟国进行和平谈判。哈尔德实际上派了一名中间人去联系其他几位主要将军，费多尔·冯·博克（Fedor von Bock）、格特·冯·伦德施泰特（Gerd von Rundstedt），这些将军我们在本系列节目中会经常提到。这些将军说，是的，我也不喜欢进攻西方、重演1914年那一幕的想法。
But I don't think we can do a coup because I don't think our junior officers would obey us. you know, and actually I think they're right because this is what happens in 1944 with Operation Valky, Tom Cruise filmed the Staufenberg plot. And Haldor says, well, I wonder what the public would think, and this tells you something about the class background of these generals. Haldor asks his father's chauffeur, what do you think the German people would think if there was a coup against Hitler?
但我认为我们不能发动政变，因为我不认为我们的初级军官会服从我们。你知道，实际上我认为他们是对的，因为这就是1944年“瓦尔基里行动”中发生的事情，汤姆·克鲁斯拍过关于施陶芬贝格阴谋的电影。哈尔德说，嗯，我想知道公众会怎么想，这说明了这些将军的阶级背景。哈尔德问他父亲的司机，如果发生针对希特勒的政变，你认为德国人民会怎么想？
And the chauffeur says, what, people love the Fuhrer, you know, they would be appalled. This would be a terrible thing, and Haldor is very shocked by this, and then goes back and says, oh, this is clearly a bad plan, because the chauffeur thinks... And we're going to bunk off this. Yeah. We come to a decisive day, which is the 5th of November, 1939. If the attack is going to happen on the 12th as Hitler wants, they have to confirm the orders to make operational preparations at lunchtime this day.
司机说，什么，人们爱元首，他们会感到震惊的。这会是一件可怕的事情。哈尔德对此感到非常震惊，然后回去说，哦，这显然是个糟糕的计划，因为司机认为……我们要逃避这个。是的。我们来到了决定性的一天，即1939年11月5日。如果进攻要像希特勒希望的那样在12日进行，他们必须在这一天的午餐时间确认作战准备命令。
At midday, Halder and Browkech go into the Reich Chancellor to try to persuade Hitler to call it off. And some of the plotters definitely know that they've gone to have this meeting. And they're hoping Hitler will say no. And then Browcich will have the guts to finally order this coup. Browcich goes in. Haldah waits outside. Haldor is now carrying a loaded revolver in case he gets the chance to be with Hitler alone. And he could shoot Hitler.
中午，哈尔德和布劳希奇进入帝国总理府，试图说服希特勒取消计划。一些阴谋者确实知道他们去开了这个会。他们希望希特勒会说不。然后布劳希奇就会有胆量最终下令发动政变。布劳希奇进去了，哈尔德在外面等。哈尔德现在带着一把装满子弹的左轮手枪，以防他有机会单独见到希特勒。他可以射杀希特勒。
So Browcich weighed down by his debts, goes in to see Hitler. He's really nervous, kind of shaky. And he says, oh, mine, Fuhrer, you know, I don't actually think we're ready to take on France and Britain. I think it's a very bad idea. When I look at the Polish campaign, there are a few kind of flaws and stuff. I think possibly if we did attack in the West, it might turn out like in 1918. And this is the kind of fighting talk that Hitler loves, right? Yeah.
所以布劳希奇背负着债务，进去见希特勒。他非常紧张，有点发抖。他说，哦，我的元首，你知道，我其实认为我们还没有准备好对付法国和英国。我认为这是一个非常糟糕的主意。当我回顾波兰战役时，有一些缺陷之类的。我想如果我们真的进攻西方，结果可能会像1918年那样。这就是希特勒最喜欢听的那种战斗言论，对吧？是的。
So as soon as he mentions 1980, right, 1918, the most traumatic moment of Hitler's life when he cried in the sanatorium at the news of Germany's defeat. As soon as Browkich mentions 1918, Hitler goes absolutely bonkers. It's kind of spittle-flecked rage. He says, the problem is not the troops. The troops are great. The troops love me. The problem is Army High Command, which is in Zossin, which is a kind of suburb of Berlin.
所以他一提到1918年，希特勒一生中最痛苦的时刻，当他听到德国战败的消息在疗养院哭泣时。布劳希奇一提到1918年，希特勒就彻底疯了。这是一种唾沫横飞的愤怒。他说，问题不在于部队。部队很棒。部队爱我。问题在于陆军最高统帅部，它在佐森（Zossen），那是柏林的一个郊区。
He says, I know the spirit of Zossan, and I will destroy it. And then he storms out of the room and he slams the door. Browcich, broken man. Wets himself. Yeah, it's basically shaking like a jelly. Or as Americans would say, presumably it's gelo. Jell-old. Right, exactly.
他说，我知道佐森的精神，我会摧毁它。然后他冲出房间，砰地关上了门。布劳希奇，一个破碎的人。尿了裤子。是的，基本上像果冻一样颤抖。或者像美国人说的，大概是明胶（Jello）。明胶。对，没错。
He goes out, shaking like a jello. Terrified, blood drain from his features. And he says to Haldor, this is what happened. and Halder says, what? He was talking about Zossin, about Army High Command at Zossan. Oh, he must know that I've been, you know, we've been having these chats. Zossin, is that where Haldah lives? No, it's where he has his office.
他走出来，像果冻一样颤抖。惊恐万分，脸色苍白。他对哈尔德说，事情就是这样。哈尔德说，什么？他在谈论佐森，谈论佐森的陆军最高统帅部。哦，他一定知道我一直在，你知道，我们一直在进行这些谈话。佐森，那是哈尔德住的地方吗？不，那是他办公室所在地。
So they have, that's the offices of Army High Command. So he thinks Christ the Gestapo are onto us. And Haldor rushes back to Zosson to his office. And he gets frantically gets all these papers and kind of destroys them. So meanwhile, while they're doing that, Hitler gives the order. Go ahead. The invasion will start on the 12th of November. Now, Lister's may be thinking, but hold on, there wasn't an invasion in the West on the 12th of November?
所以他们有，那是陆军最高统帅部的办公室。所以他想，天哪，盖世太保盯上我们了。哈尔德冲回佐森的办公室。他疯狂地把所有这些文件拿出来并销毁了。与此同时，当他们这样做的时候，希特勒下达了命令。继续。入侵将于11月12日开始。现在，听众们可能会想，等等，11月12日并没有发生对西方的入侵？
And here's the mad thing about all this. Hitler gets the order and immediately the weather changes and it just starts raining. And they have to call it off for that reason. Basically, the winter rains have started. The ground is turned to mud. The panzers won't be able to get through because it's so muddy. And they say, oh, well, after all that, actually, we'll have to just postpone it to the spring of 1940. Anyway, and so even Hitler accepts that.
这就是这一切疯狂的地方。希特勒下达了命令，天气立刻变了，开始下雨。他们不得不因此取消计划。基本上，冬雨开始了。地面变成了泥潭。装甲部队因为太泥泞而无法通过。他们说，哦，好吧，经过这一切，实际上，我们只能把它推迟到1940年春天。总之，甚至希特勒也接受了这一点。
Hitler's not going to argue with the weather. I don't know. Force of will. I think even Hitler bows in the face of the climate. At least at this point, of course, he doesn't in 1941. They make a terrible mess of it. I was going to say, because it didn't stop him invading Russia. No, you're right. But anyway, they postponed it.
希特勒不会和天气争论。我不知道。意志的力量。我想即使是希特勒在气候面前也会低头。当然，至少在这一点上，他在1941年并没有这样做。他们把事情搞得一团糟。我正想说，因为这并没有阻止他入侵俄罗斯。不，你是对的。但无论如何，他们推迟了。
So the chance for the army to strike is gone, and Hitler is actually safe for the time being. Or is he, Dominic? Because three days later, so this is the 8th of November, 1939, he is going to Munich, isn't he? because it's the anniversary of the Beer Hall Putsch, kind of sacred moment in the Nazi calendar. And it's traditional that Hitler will go to the Beer Hall and he will address an audience of his old comrades, the old fighters. And he's scheduled to arrive at 8.30 and he will then speak for not half an hour, not one hour, but two hours. Dominic and listeners, as Hitler walks into that beer hall, surrounded. by his bodyguards. A bomb is literally ticking. And we will be back after the break to say
所以军队出击的机会消失了，希特勒暂时安全了。或者他安全吗，多米尼克？因为三天后，也就是1939年11月8日，他要去慕尼黑，不是吗？因为那是啤酒馆政变的周年纪念日，纳粹日历中神圣的时刻。按照传统，希特勒会去啤酒馆，向他的老战友、老战士们发表讲话。他计划在8点30分到达，然后他将演讲，不是半小时，不是一小时，而是两小时。多米尼克和听众们，当希特勒走进那个啤酒馆时，被他的保镖包围着。一枚炸弹正在滴答作响。我们休息后回来告诉大家
what happens. This question is brought to you by People's Postcode Lottery. You know, history is full of surprises, moments that no one saw coming, moments when the world turned on its axis and everything changed. And as this year draws to a close, Dominic, people's postcode Lottery's biggest ever prize pot, that's 38.2 million pounds, will be shared among winning postcodes across Great Britain in their December draw, with 30% of every ticket supporting charities and good causes in local communities. So, wonderful stuff. Yeah, wonderful. And they've asked us a very fitting question. And here is the question, everybody. So, of all the great moments of change, from the fall of Rome to the rise of the internet,
发生了什么。本期节目由人民邮政编码彩票（People's Postcode Lottery）赞助。你知道，历史充满了惊喜，那些没人预见到的时刻，世界转动轴心、一切都改变的时刻。随着今年接近尾声，多米尼克，人民邮政编码彩票有史以来最大的奖池，即3820万英镑，将在12月的抽奖中由英国各地的中奖邮编分享，每张彩票的30%将支持当地社区的慈善机构和公益事业。所以，真是太棒了。是的，太棒了。他们问了我们一个非常贴切的问题。这就是问题，大家。所以，在所有伟大的变革时刻中，从罗马的陷落到互联网的兴起，
what was the single biggest ever turning point in history? So Tom, turning points, I mean, I don't know what defines them, scale, speed, legacy. You think of the, I don't know, the fall of Rome, the rise of the printing press. Do you have an answer for the greatest turning point in history? I think there are two candidates. One of them would be the agrarian revolution, so the process by which hunter-gatherers came to settle down, plant crops, and those crops then enabled in the long run the emergence of urbanism. But I think possibly even profounder in its long-term consequences than the agrarian
历史上最大的转折点是什么？所以汤姆，转折点，我的意思是，我不知道是什么定义了它们，规模、速度、遗产。你会想到，我不知道，罗马的陷落，印刷术的兴起。你对历史上最大的转折点有答案吗？我认为有两个候选者。其中之一是农业革命，即狩猎采集者开始定居、种植农作物，而这些农作物从长远来看促成了城市化的出现。但我认为，在长期后果上，可能比农业革命更深远的是
revolution is the industrial revolution. And I'm not saying that just because it began here in Britain, though hooray for Britain for kicking it all off. But we would not be able to record this episode and have it heard by you without that process of change. I mean, We live in such a technologically advanced world now, and that would not have happened without the Industrial Revolution. Massively improved living standards, led to urbanism, all these kinds of things. I suppose the difficulty of all these things is about measuring their impact, isn't it? Is it about the immediate shock? Is it about the lasting consequences?
工业革命。我这么说不仅仅是因为它始于英国，尽管为英国开启这一切欢呼。但如果没有那个变革过程，我们就无法录制这一集并让你们听到。我的意思是，我们现在生活在一个技术如此先进的世界里，如果没有工业革命，这一切都不会发生。生活水平大幅提高，导致了城市化，所有这些事情。我想所有这些事情的困难在于衡量它们的影响，不是吗？是关于即时的冲击吗？是关于持久的后果吗？
And those consequences are often very complicated. The Industrial Revolution's legacy, for example, cities, capitalism, carbon. Of course, it gave us the great age of Victorian philanthropy. thinking of philanthropy, the People's Postcode Lottery is brilliant on this. So take an example at ActionAid, the charity that they support. It empowers communities. It supports women and children to build safer, fairer futures. And that's the kind of thing that we love, don't we, Tom? Oh, we love that. And I guess just kind of wrapping up these reflections on great turning points, I suppose one of the problems is that you're always liable to think that the process
而这些后果往往非常复杂。例如，工业革命的遗产：城市、资本主义、碳。当然，它给了我们维多利亚时代伟大的慈善事业。想到慈善，人民邮政编码彩票在这方面非常出色。以他们支持的慈善机构ActionAid为例。它赋予社区权力。它支持妇女和儿童建立更安全、更公平的未来。这就是我们喜欢的那种事情，不是吗，汤姆？哦，我们喜欢那个。我想在总结这些关于伟大转折点的思考时，我想问题之一是你总是容易认为你正在经历的变革过程
of change that you are living through is the most significant. And then some other great revolution, great turning point may happen. And people will move on and think that that's the biggest. But we are living through the consequences of the Industrial Revolution now. And so that's why I think I would choose it. But certainly the great turning points in history do remind us just how quickly the world can change. And often it kind of creeps up when people aren't expecting it. And that same spirit of surprise, Tom, sits at the heart of people's postcode lottery's biggest ever prize pot in this December's drawers. So there's 38.2 million pounds to be shared among winning postcodes across Great Britain. And 30% of every ticket supports
是最重要的。然后可能会发生其他伟大的革命、伟大的转折点。人们会继续前进，认为那是最大的。但我们现在正生活在工业革命的后果中。所以这就是为什么我想选择它。但毫无疑问，历史上的伟大转折点确实提醒我们世界变化得有多快。而且往往在人们不期待的时候悄然而至。同样的惊喜精神，汤姆，也存在于人民邮政编码彩票12月抽奖中有史以来最大的奖池中。所以有3820万英镑将由英国各地的中奖邮编分享。每张彩票的30%支持
charities and good causes, including action aid. Yeah, because behind every ticket, there is something bigger at work, and that is people coming together to make real change happen. Is your door in the draw. Sign up before midnight on the 30th of November at people's postcodeottery.com.com. Hack the holidays with the PC Holiday Insiders Report. Try this PC Porchetta. Crackling, craveworthy. You gonna eat that? Who are you? I'm the voice for the next ad. Car commercial. But I noticed that show-stopping roast and... Help yourself. Mmm, designed for indulgence. Precision crafted to navigate every corner of my mouth. All for just $18. Okay, okay. Try the season's hottest flavors from the PC Holiday Insiders Report. Please feast responsibly. Hello everyone and welcome back to the rest of history.
慈善机构和公益事业，包括ActionAid。是的，因为每张彩票背后都有更伟大的力量在起作用，那就是人们团结起来实现真正的变革。你的门牌号在抽奖名单里吗？在11月30日午夜前注册，网址是people's postcodelottery.com。用PC假日内部报告来破解假期。试试这个PC意式烤肉卷（Porchetta）。酥脆，令人垂涎。你要吃那个吗？你是谁？我是下一个广告的配音。汽车广告。但我注意到了那个引人注目的烤肉，还有……自便。嗯，专为放纵而设计。精密制作，可以导航到我嘴里的每一个角落。只需18美元。好吧，好吧。从PC假日内部报告中尝试本季最热门的风味。请负责任地享用。大家好，欢迎回到“历史的其余部分”（The Rest is History）。
It is the evening of the 8th of November 1939. Adolf Hitler has arrived in the beer hall in Munich for the annual celebration of the beer hall putch. But Dominic, little does he know that his life, the future of Germany, the course of world history itself, are all hanging in the balance. Right. Now, we'll get back to, I notice you skipped pronouncing the name of the beer hall, the Burger Breye Keller in Munich, but we'll get back there. I don't want to frighten people with foreign languages. Okay. Okay.
那是1939年11月8日的傍晚。阿道夫·希特勒已经抵达慕尼黑的啤酒馆，参加啤酒馆政变的年度庆祝活动。但多米尼克，他不知道他的生命、德国的未来、世界历史的进程本身，都悬于一线。好吧。现在，我们将回到，我注意到你跳过了啤酒馆的名字，慕尼黑的贝格布劳凯勒（Bürgerbräukeller），但我们会回到那里的。我不想用外语吓唬人。好吧。好吧。
Well, we'll get back there in a second bit. Should we pull back the camera? Let's do that. Like a top documentary to set the scene. to set the scene and explain precisely why this bomb is ticking. So among ordinary Germans, although they were delighted by the quick victory over Poland, they are not suffused with war enthusiasm. They're actually quite anxious.
好吧，我们一会儿再回到那里。我们应该把镜头拉远吗？让我们这样做。像一部顶级纪录片那样来设定场景。设定场景并准确解释为什么这枚炸弹正在滴答作响。在普通德国人中，尽管他们对波兰的迅速胜利感到高兴，但他们并没有沉浸在战争的热情中。他们实际上相当焦虑。
And the reason for that is that if you're an ordinary German, life has definitely got worse in the last few months. So since the war started, if you work in an export industry, you've lost your export market. markets. German factories are short of raw materials. Every last penny of the government's budget is now going into weapons and munitions. And the Nazis had brought in an immediate austerity program as soon as the war broke out. So that means higher taxes. There's no more overtime. They cut leave for workers. Wages are frozen and so on and so forth. And there's no coffee, is there? So they're all having to drink. What is it? Mucker fuck. The fake mokker, which is made from chickory. Yeah, there's a lot of that kind of stuff. And they, of course, remember it from the First World War.
原因在于，如果你是一个普通德国人，过去几个月的生活绝对变糟了。所以自从战争开始以来，如果你在出口行业工作，你就失去了出口市场。德国工厂缺乏原材料。政府预算的每一分钱现在都投入到了武器和弹药中。纳粹在战争爆发后立即实施了紧缩计划。这意味着更高的税收。没有更多的加班费。他们削减了工人的假期。工资被冻结等等。而且没有咖啡，不是吗？所以他们都不得不喝。那是什么？Mucker-fuck。那种用菊苣做的假咖啡。是的，有很多那种东西。当然，他们还记得第一次世界大战时的情况。
Older people remember how hard things got. Although they can't go on strike, there's a lot of absenteers, and people stop turning up to work. They start refusing to do overtime. And so daily life is definitely getting harder. People feel they're working longer hours for stagnant pay. Food is more expensive. It's a very, very cold winter in 1939, 1940, but they can't get hold of coal easily. even the trains. So the German trains now actually are terrible, the worst in Europe, the worst
老年人记得当时的情况有多艰难。虽然他们不能罢工，但有很多旷工，人们开始不再去上班。他们开始拒绝加班。所以日常生活绝对变得越来越难。人们觉得他们工作时间更长，工资却停滞不前。食物更贵了。1939年到1940年的冬天非常非常冷，但他们很难买到煤炭。甚至火车也是。所以德国的火车现在实际上很糟糕，是欧洲最差的，准点率记录最差。
punctuality record. But they're pretty poor in 1939 anyway. So the idea that fascists make their trains run on time is wrong. The pressure of war is too much for the German train system. And there are two crashes that kill more than 200 people. So there's great outrage about this. And above all, people are obviously worried, you know, Britain and France, you know, they're serious countries. They could beat us as they did, you know, a generation ago. And one of the people who's worried about this is a totally unremarkable guy called Georg Elza. And Elzer, I think, is a really nice example of German politics in the 1930s. Richard Evans kind of uses him in his great book on the Nazis, precisely because he's not very political. He's not Jewish, is he? He's not
但它们在1939年本来就很差。所以法西斯让火车准点运行的想法是错误的。战争的压力对德国铁路系统来说太大了。发生了两起事故，造成200多人死亡。所以人们对此非常愤怒。最重要的是，人们显然很担心，你知道，英国和法国，你知道，他们是认真的国家。他们可以像一代人前那样打败我们。其中一个担心这一点的人是一个完全不起眼的家伙，叫格奥尔格·埃尔泽（Georg Elser）。埃尔泽，我认为，是20世纪30年代德国政治的一个非常好的例子。理查德·埃文斯（Richard Evans）在他的纳粹巨著中引用了他，正是因为他不是很政治化。他不是犹太人，对吧？他不是
particularly religious like the White Rose campaign as in due course would be. He's just a totally boring every man. And Elsa came from Wurttemberg, sort of southwestern Germany, born in 1983. His father was an alcoholic and gave him, he was a violent man and gave gay august kind of lifelong hatred of bullies and of authority. He becomes a carpenter. He's a very nondescript person. He's short. He's kind of quiet. He has girlfriends. He has a son out of wedlock, but he's not married. He's not a reader. He doesn't read books. He doesn't even really read the newspapers so he doesn't know what's going on. And in that respect, he's completely normal. Although there are kind of radios everywhere, aren't there? I mean, this is the thing,
特别虔诚，不像后来的“白玫瑰”运动那样。他只是一个完全无聊的普通人。埃尔泽来自符腾堡，德国西南部，出生于1903年。他的父亲是个酒鬼，是个暴力的人，给了奥古斯特一种对恶霸和权威的终身仇恨。他成为了一名木匠。他是一个非常不起眼的人。他个子不高。他有点安静。他有女朋友。他有一个私生子，但他没有结婚。他不读书。他不看书。他甚至不怎么看报纸，所以他不知道发生了什么。在这方面，他是完全正常的。虽然到处都有收音机，不是吗？我的意思是，这就是重点，
that there are more radios in Germany than anywhere else. And even those you don't have them have to listen to them kind of blaring out from cafes and things. So presumably he is familiar with at least the headlines, I guess. Yeah, of course, he's familiar with the headlines. And of course, he's drawn into politics almost despite himself as everybody is. So he belongs to the Woodworkers Union. Because he belongs to the Union, he voted for the communists in the late 20s and early 30s, because he thought they would get workers a better deal. And he'd actually joined their kind of paramilitary group, the Red Front fighters, but he never turned up to meetings. It's just not really his thing. He doesn't care for the Nazis. He never
德国的收音机比任何地方都多。即使那些没有收音机的人也必须听着咖啡馆里传出的声音。所以大概他至少熟悉头条新闻，我想。是的，当然，他熟悉头条新闻。当然，他几乎是不由自主地被卷入了政治，就像每个人一样。所以他属于木工工会。因为他属于工会，他在20世纪20年代末和30年代初投票支持共产党，因为他认为他们会给工人更好的待遇。他甚至加入了他们的准军事组织，“红色阵线战士同盟”，但他从不去参加会议。这真的不是他的风格。他不关心纳粹。他从来没有
voted in elections and referendums under the Third Reich. And his reason was not ideological, really. It was that he didn't think they were for the working man. He didn't think they got working people a good deal. He said, you know, our pay's not very good, all of this kind of thing. And Georg Elza, who's too young to have fought in the First World War, when he thinks that a second World War is coming, he becomes very anxious about it and very alarmed. So the key thing for him is late 1938 when Hitler turns on Czechoslovakia. And Georg Elza becomes convinced that Hitler's going to drag us into a war,
在第三帝国的选举和公投中投票。他的原因并不是意识形态上的，真的。而是他认为他们不是为工人阶级服务的。他不认为他们给了劳动人民好的待遇。他说，你知道，我们的工资不是很好，诸如此类的事情。而格奥尔格·埃尔泽，他太年轻了，没有参加第一次世界大战，当他认为第二次世界大战即将来临时，他变得非常焦虑和惊恐。所以对他来说，关键是1938年底，希特勒转向捷克斯洛伐克。格奥尔格·埃尔泽确信希特勒会把我们拖入战争，
and poor working-class Germans, like me, will pay the price for this. This is where he becomes unusual. He decides, well, the only way to stop this is to get rid of Hitler. and the Nazi top brass. I need to eliminate the leadership. And is he doing this entirely on his own? Entirely on his own. This is the mad thing.
像我这样的贫穷工人阶级德国人将为此付出代价。这就是他变得不寻常的地方。他决定，好吧，阻止这一切的唯一方法就是除掉希特勒。和纳粹高层。我需要消灭领导层。他是完全独自一人做这件事吗？完全独自一人。这就是疯狂的地方。
So he's just a carpenter, right? He's a nobody. He just says, well, clearly nobody else is going to do this, so I'm going to do it. He's a have a go hero. He's a have a go hero. And he reads that every 8th of November, the Nazis always meet in the Burger Breuerrekeller,
所以他只是个木匠，对吧？他是个无名小卒。他只是说，好吧，显然没有其他人会做这件事，所以我要做。他是个“敢于尝试的英雄”。他是个“敢于尝试的英雄”。他读到每年的11月8日，纳粹总是在贝格布劳凯勒（Bürgerbräukeller）聚会，
this beer hall in Munich, and they have their little anniversary celebration. And so on the 8th of November, 1938, Gael goes off to Munich and he waits outside, just stands in that street outside. He waits to everybody's gone, Hitler, Gering, whoever else, and the crowd has gone. And then he goes inside the beer hall to sort of sneaks in to have a look around. And he realizes two things. Number one, the security is abject.
这个慕尼黑的啤酒馆，他们有他们的小周年纪念庆祝活动。所以1938年11月8日，格奥尔格去了慕尼黑，他在外面等，就站在外面的那条街上。他等到所有人都走了，希特勒、戈林，无论还有谁，人群也散了。然后他走进啤酒馆，偷偷溜进去看看。他意识到两件事。第一，安保极其糟糕。
Security is terrible because the Nazis insist on doing the security themselves. They don't let the police do it. And the Nazis are useless, completely incompetent. Number two, he can see where Hitler was. speaking, and there's a pillar right behind it, and he thinks, well, if I could get a bomb in that pillar, I'd kill Hitler, and I'd kill all his entourage. Now, as luck would have it, like so many Germans at this point, Georg has basically been reassigned to work in an armaments factory. Oh, right. So there were lots of timers and explosives. Exactly. So over that winter,
安保太差了，因为纳粹坚持自己做安保。他们不让警察做。而纳粹毫无用处，完全无能。第二，他能看到希特勒演讲的地方，后面有一根柱子，他想，如果我能把炸弹放进那根柱子里，我就能杀死希特勒，我就能杀死他所有的随从。现在，幸运的是，像当时许多德国人一样，格奥尔格基本上被重新分配到一家军工厂工作。哦，对了。所以有很多定时器和炸药。没错。所以那个冬天，
he steals loads of fuses and detonators from work, kind of just shoves from his pocket and walks out with them. And the following spring, so April 1939, he comes back to the beer hall, he kind of Waits to everyone else has gone late at night, and then he takes photos, he measures it up. He's a carpenter, so he knows what he's doing. He works out exactly how big the bomb would have to be. He steals some dynamite from a quarry, and he starts doing tests in his parents' back garden. God. So, I mean, if your son started doing that, you might be perturbed, but clearly not.
他从工作中偷了很多引信和雷管，就塞进兜里走出来了。第二年春天，也就是1939年4月，他回到啤酒馆，他等到深夜所有人都走了，然后他拍照，测量尺寸。他是木匠，所以他知道自己在做什么。他计算出炸弹到底需要多大。他从采石场偷了一些炸药，开始在他父母的后花园里做测试。天哪。所以，我的意思是，如果你的儿子开始那样做，你可能会感到不安，但显然没有。
Impressive forward planning, right? He's the most impressive person in this whole series, frankly, and this series has got Churchill, isn't it? So he is so meticulous and he really plays the long game. Mendefica, he came up with this idea now almost a year ago. Yeah. I mean, really playing the long game. Really playing the long game. August 1939, the 5th of August, he comes back to Munich.
令人印象深刻的前瞻性规划，对吧？坦率地说，他是整个系列中最令人印象深刻的人，而这个系列里还有丘吉尔，不是吗？所以他非常细致，他真的在下一盘大棋。我的天，他几乎在一年前就想出了这个主意。是的。我的意思是，真的在下一盘大棋。真的在下一盘大棋。1939年8月，8月5日，他回到慕尼黑。
He rents a flat and he starts going to the beer hall every night to have his dinner and to have like a pint of German ale. Very cunning. And every night he gets into a storeroom and he hides in this store room and he waits in this store room and he waits till everybody else has gone and the staff. of all gone home. Then when the coast is clear, he comes out the storeroom, he goes up to the pillar, he carves out this hole, and he is so meticulous. So basically, he builds a secret door in the wooden cladding of the pillar, that only he knows how to open, that looks just like
他租了一间公寓，开始每天晚上去啤酒馆吃晚饭，喝一品脱德国啤酒。非常狡猾。每天晚上他都溜进储藏室，躲在这个储藏室里，他躲在这个储藏室里，等着所有人都走了，员工们也都回家了。然后当没人的时候，他从储藏室出来，走到柱子前，凿出这个洞，他非常细致。所以基本上，他在柱子的木镶板上做了一个秘密门，只有他知道怎么打开，看起来就像
the rest of the cladding. Then behind that, he hollows out a sort of a niche in the brickwork of the pillar with a special chamber. He lines this chamber with tin so that if you knock on it, It won't sound hollow. So that takes him 30 nights. 30 nights he's going in there, having his sausages and stuff, wait until everyone's gone home and doing this. And becoming a familiar face in the hall. Of course, a much loved regular.
其余的镶板一样。然后在那后面，他用一个特殊的腔室在柱子的砖砌中挖出一个壁龛。他用锡衬里这个腔室，这样如果你敲它，它就不会听起来是空的。所以这花了他30个晚上。30个晚上他都在那里，吃着香肠之类的东西，等所有人都回家，做这件事。并成为大厅里的熟面孔。当然，一个深受喜爱的常客。
And then on the night of the 1st of November, he puts the explosives in. Three nights later, there's a dance in the beer hall. He buys a ticket to the dance, presumably he doesn't do any dancing. He waits until 1 o'clock. Everyone's gone home. and that's the night that he puts in the timer and the detonator. So now it's there, it's ready to go. What is almost the striking as the kind of meticulousness of his preparations?
然后在11月1日晚上，他放进了炸药。三天后，啤酒馆里有一场舞会。他买了一张舞会门票，大概他没跳舞。他等到1点钟。所有人都回家了。那就是他放入定时器和雷管的夜晚。所以现在它在那里，准备好了。什么几乎和他的准备工作的细致程度一样令人震惊？
It's the kind of incompetence of Nazi security. I mean, you'd think that they would go around checking for things like this if Hitler's coming. I don't know, because I was thinking precisely this about the whole business of hiding in the storeroom. I was almost tempted, I mean, it would be a mad thing for me to do in part of my research, to try hiding in the storeroom of a restaurant or something and to see whether I could pull it off, whether I could hide in the storeroom, come out. The headlines would write themselves.
是纳粹安保的无能。我的意思是，你会认为如果希特勒要来，他们会到处检查这样的事情。我不知道，因为我刚才就在想关于躲在储藏室里的整件事。我几乎想尝试一下，我的意思是，作为我研究的一部分，我去做这件事会很疯狂，尝试躲在餐馆的储藏室里之类的，看看我是否能成功，看看我是否能躲在储藏室里，出来。头条新闻会自己写出来。
Come out and try to put a bomb in, I don't know, the River Cafe or something. I don't think I could do it. Well, I'm rubbish at crafts, so undoubtedly could do it. Well, also, I mean, you wouldn't want to experiment with explosives in your garden, would you? No, I wouldn't.
出来并尝试放一枚炸弹，我不知道，在河畔咖啡馆（River Cafe）之类的。我不认为我能做到。好吧，我不擅长手工，所以毫无疑问能做到。好吧，而且，我的意思是，你不会想在你的花园里试验炸药，对吧？不，我不会。
I definitely wouldn't. Yeah, but this is all by way of making his preparations are all the more striking. Yeah, I guess the other thing is people aren't going to come up to him and say, oh, I'm a member of the rest of history club. How wonderful to see you in the restaurant. Yeah, that's true. What are you doing with that gelic night?
我绝对不会。是的，但这都是为了让他的准备工作更加引人注目。是的，我想另一件事是人们不会走过来对他说，哦，我是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员。在餐馆见到你真是太好了。是的，那是真的。你拿着那个明胶在做什么？
You've come here for the last three weeks. You have a very strange and unexpected life. Anyway, 7th of November, he visits the beer hall one last time. He has his pint and whatnot. He waits until after closing. Then he checks the pillar, he puts his ear to the pillar. And he can just hear the clock ticking. And he says, brilliant.
你过去三周都来这里。你有一个非常奇怪和意想不到的生活。总之，11月7日，他最后一次访问啤酒馆。他喝了他的啤酒之类的。他等到关门后。然后他检查柱子，他把耳朵贴在柱子上。他能听到时钟滴答作响。他说，太棒了。
They're coming tomorrow. Yeah, tomorrow's the day. So he's set the timer. It will go off at 9.20 in the evening of the 8th. So that will be just over an hour, probably, into Hitler's speech. All the party faithful, the bigwigs will be there. Everything is prepared. And so it is.
他们明天就来。是的，明天就是那一天。所以他设置了定时器。它将在8日晚上9点20分爆炸。所以那将是希特勒演讲开始后一个多小时，大概。所有的党内忠实分子、大人物都会在那里。一切都准备好了。所以就是这样。
On the 8th, the day that it's going to go off, Gael very contented, leaves Munich, and he's heading for late Constance. And there he's going to cross the border into Switzerland. and by the time he crosses the border, he is confident that Hitler will be dead. Meanwhile, Hitler is on his way to Munich for this meeting. Now, he arrives at the Beer Hall at 8 rather than 8.30, which was originally planned. Now, the reason for this is precisely because of all the mad arguments with the generals about the attack in the West.
在8日，也就是它要爆炸的那天，格奥尔格非常满足，离开了慕尼黑，他正前往康斯坦茨湖。在那里他要越过边境进入瑞士。当他越过边境时，他确信希特勒已经死了。与此同时，希特勒正在前往慕尼黑参加这次会议的路上。现在，他在8点而不是原计划的8点30分到达啤酒馆。现在，原因正是因为与将军们关于进攻西方的所有疯狂争论。
So just the day before, the 7th of November, that was the day that he had postponed the operation because of the bad weather. And they're going to have another meeting about it on the 9th tomorrow. Because there's loads to discuss. Yeah, when are we going to do it? We'll do the troops, blah, blah, blah, blah. And so Hitler was like, oh, I've got to go. I've got that. Basically, it's like you talking about your diary, Tom.
所以就在前一天，11月7日，那是他因为恶劣天气推迟行动的那一天。他们明天9日还要再开一次会讨论它。因为有很多要讨论的。是的，我们什么时候做？我们会做部队，等等等等。所以希特勒当时想，哦，我得走了。我有那个。基本上，就像你谈论你的日记一样，汤姆。
So I agreed to do this a year ago. This commitment has been staring at me all this time. I'd love to get out of it, but I can't. I have to go to Munich and get it done and dusted back on the train. and prepare the next episode of the rest is history. So in that way, Hitler is like me. Exactly. It's very similar.
所以我一年前同意做这件事。这个承诺一直盯着我。我很想摆脱它，但我不能。我必须去慕尼黑把它做完，然后回到火车上。并准备“历史的其余部分”的下一集。所以从这个意义上说，希特勒就像我。没错。非常相似。
So it turns up to the beer hall. There's 3,000 people there, these so-called old fighters. And at 10 past 8, Hitler gets up. And he starts delivering this massive rant, I'm sorry to say, against Britain. So very poor from Hitler. But here's the thing. Now, normally you'd expect Hitler to be ranting about Mr. Churchill and whatnot for two hours.
所以他出现在啤酒馆。那里有3000人，这些所谓的“老战士”。在8点10分，希特勒站了起来。他开始发表这篇巨大的咆哮，我很抱歉地说，是针对英国的。所以希特勒表现很差。但重点是。现在，通常你会期望希特勒咆哮丘吉尔先生之类的两个小时。
No. It's quite a short speech by his standards. So he gets to his climax. There's peroration at 907. And the clock is due to go off at 920. He finishes the speech. There is a torrent of applause. Everybody has very much enjoyed it.
不。按他的标准，这是一个相当短的演讲。所以他在9点07分达到了高潮。那个结束语。时钟定在9点20分响。他结束了演讲。掌声如潮。每个人都非常喜欢它。
Now, normally he would stay in the room for half an hour, working the room and shaking the hands of his old comrades. But he wants to be back in Berlin by bedtime. So he leaves the hall immediately. He rushes out of the hall, whisked away by his entourage, to catch his special train. And the old fighters are very disappointed. They were looking forward to shaking the hand of the furor. And they begin to make their way out of the hall.
现在，通常他会留在房间里半小时，在房间里走动，与他的老战友握手。但他想在睡觉前回到柏林。所以他立即离开了大厅。他冲出大厅，被他的随从匆匆带走，去赶他的专列。老战士们非常失望。他们期待着与元首握手。他们开始走出大厅。
And the staff come in to start clearing up. Now, meanwhile, Hitler's got onto it, he's made the train, his special train taking back to Berlin. And he's on the train. They're rattling through the countryside. He's actually sitting with gerbils, and they're having a massive bitch about the Catholic church. And then in Nuremberg, the train is stopped unexpectedly.
员工们进来开始清理。现在，与此同时，希特勒已经上了火车，他的专列带他回柏林。他在火车上。他们在乡村中疾驰。他实际上正和戈培尔坐在一起，他们正在大肆抱怨天主教会。然后在纽伦堡，火车意外地停了下来。
And Hitler's like, what's going on? and a load of officers get on the train and they say there's been an explosion at the beer hall a bomb has gone off just after you left and at first Hitler thinks it's a joke or I mean God knows what kind of jokes they're telling and kind of Nazi high command but he thinks this is great banter
希特勒说，怎么回事？一大群军官上了火车，他们说啤酒馆发生了爆炸，你离开后不久炸弹就爆炸了。起初希特勒以为这是个玩笑，或者我的天知道他们在纳粹高层讲什么笑话，但他认为这是很好的玩笑。
or it's a hoax of some kind and then more news comes 13 minutes after he left at 920 the bomb went off it went just as gay or girls had planned the upper gallery collapsed the roof collapse. But by that point, the place was emptying. So three people only were killed at once. Five more people will die their injuries in the next few hours. And more than 60 have been injured,
或者某种恶作剧，然后更多的消息传来，在他离开13分钟后，9点20分，炸弹爆炸了。它正如格奥尔格·埃尔泽计划的那样。上层看台倒塌了，屋顶倒塌了。但到那时，那个地方正在清空。所以只有三个人当场死亡。五个人将在接下来的几个小时内因伤死亡。还有60多人受伤，
but none of them are the Nazi big names that Elsa wanted to get. And all but one of those who died are members of the Nazi party. Yeah, exactly. I think they're the person, a member of staff of the beer hall, maybe? Because you're thinking maybe it's members of staff who got killed because they were doing the tidying up, but it is actually Nazis. At first, people thought when the bomb went off, it's an air raid by the British. And then they realised it's a bomb. They still think it's the British Secret Service. So the British kind of live, as it were, rent-free in the Nazis' heads.
但他们都不是埃尔泽想要除掉的纳粹大人物。死者中除一人外，都是纳粹党员。是的，没错。我想他们是那个人，啤酒馆的员工，也许？因为你在想也许是员工被杀了，因为他们在清理，但实际上是纳粹。起初，当炸弹爆炸时，人们以为是英国人的空袭。然后他们意识到这是一枚炸弹。他们仍然认为是英国特勤局。所以英国人，可以说，免费住在纳粹的脑子里。
And Hitler says to the SS, the SS say, we've been monitoring two British agents, actually, on the Dutch border. And Hitler says, right, bring them straight in. Like, get them across the border, bring them in for questioning. And these two British agents, you know, obviously know nothing about it. But they are trumpeted in Nazi propaganda. are these are the people who were behind the plot. So all this is going on, but what about Gil Gelsa? Has he made it across the border into Switzerland?
希特勒对党卫军说，党卫军说，我们一直在监视边境上的两名英国特工。希特勒说，好，直接把他们带进来。就像，把他们带过边境，带进来审问。而这两名英国特工，你知道，显然对此一无所知。但他们在纳粹宣传中被大肆宣扬。这些人就是阴谋背后的主谋。所以这一切都在发生，但格奥尔格·埃尔泽怎么样了？他成功越过边境进入瑞士了吗？
No. So completely by chance, when he was crossing the border, a customs post near Constance, a customs official detained him and said, you haven't got the right permit. And they sort of, you know, this was not uncommon. They didn't assume there was anything terribly sinister about it. But then they searched his pockets a couple of hours later
没有。所以完全是偶然的，当他越过边境时，康斯坦茨附近的一个海关哨所，一名海关官员拘留了他并说，你没有正确的许可证。他们有点，你知道，这并不罕见。他们没有认为这有什么特别险恶的地方。但几个小时后，他们搜查了他的口袋。
after the bomb had gone off. And they found they had wire cutters. He had a fuse. and he had a postcard of the beer hall that was absolute madness from him and they said oh this is clearly the bloke now they beat him up they tortured him Himler tortured him personally
炸弹爆炸之后。他们发现他有断线钳。他有一个引信。他还有一张啤酒馆的明信片，这对他来说简直是疯了，他们说，哦，这显然就是那个人，现在他们殴打他，折磨他，希姆莱亲自折磨他
I think stamping on him or kicking him or something until he confessed and here's the mad thing they didn't kill him in fact they treated him quite well they interned him in Saxonhausen camp and they made him a kind of special privileged prisoner
我想是踩他、踢他之类的，直到他招供，最疯狂的是他们没有杀他，事实上他们对他还不错，把他关在萨克森豪森集中营，让他成为一种特殊的优待囚犯
so he had two rooms and one of them he was allowed to use as a kind of carpentry workshop and he spent his time, he made himself a zither and spent his time playing the zither and smoking. I did not imagine
所以他有两间房，其中一间被允许用作木工车间，他花时间给自己做了一把齐特琴，花时间弹琴和抽烟。我没法想象
that people in concentration camps would be playing the zither. Well, he's playing the zither. He's not allowed to mix with other prisoners, but he was a loner so he wouldn't have wanted to mix with the prisoners anyway.
集中营里的人会弹齐特琴。好吧，他在弹齐特琴。他不被允许和其他囚犯接触，但他是个独来独往的人，所以他本来也不想和囚犯接触。
Aren't there prisoners in the camp who think that this is because he had actually been a kind of a jean provocateur that he was actually working for the Nazis to get sympathy for Hitler? Exactly.
难道营里的囚犯不认为这是因为他实际上是一个挑衅者，他实际上是在为纳粹工作以博取对希特勒的同情吗？正是如此。
that it's a false flag operation. And in fact, quite a few people thought it was a false flag operation because there was such an outpouring of sympathy for Hitler after the failure of the attack. But no, I don't think it was. I think what actually the Nazis wanted to have him fit and healthy for a show trial at the end of the war, which they would use as an exhibit against the British.
认为这是一场虚假旗帜行动。事实上，相当多的人认为这是一场虚假旗帜行动，因为在袭击失败后，人们对希特勒表现出了极大的同情。但不，我不认为是这样。我认为纳粹实际上是想让他保持健康，以便在战争结束时进行作秀审判，他们会将其作为反对英国人的证据。
They would basically frame him as a puppet of the British Secret Service and that this would be good propaganda. Because Hitler thinks that it's a British conspiracy right to the end. Exactly. Because, you know, Hitler has this Wagnerian sense of himself, doesn't he? And he needs Wagnerian enemies. A carpenter who's just, you know, a bit worried about the plight of the working classes, doesn't cut it as a kind of Nazi antagonist, I think. But also he wouldn't want to think that an ordinary German would want to kill him. It must be the British.
他们基本上会把他塑造成英国特勤局的傀儡，这将是很好的宣传。因为希特勒直到最后都认为这是一个英国阴谋。没错。因为，你知道，希特勒有一种瓦格纳式的自我意识，不是吗？他需要瓦格纳式的敌人。一个只是有点担心工人阶级困境的木匠，我认为他算不上纳粹的对手。而且他也不愿意认为一个普通的德国人会想杀他。那一定是英国人干的。
Exactly, exactly. Actually, what happened to Elsa, at the end of the war, he was moved to Daco and he was shot in April, 1945. The Nazis did get rid of him in the end. And then he was forgotten for a long time because really post-war Germans didn't really know what to make of him. But today, there's more than 60 streets and squares and things named after him in Germany. And the city of Munich has a Georg-Elzer Prize for Courage. So maybe if I did do that thing where I hid it in the river cafe. Yeah. You could win that. I could win it. Yeah. That's something to aspire to. But of course, at the time, nobody sees him as a hero at all. So all the evidence is that most ordinary Germans were absolutely horrified by this,
没错，没错。事实上，埃尔泽后来怎么样了，在战争结束时，他被转移到达豪，并于1945年4月被枪杀。纳粹最终还是除掉了他。然后他被遗忘了很长一段时间，因为战后的德国人真的不知道该如何评价他。但今天，德国有60多条街道、广场和事物以他的名字命名。慕尼黑市还设有乔治·埃尔泽勇气奖。所以也许如果我真的做了那种把它藏在河边咖啡馆的事。是的。你可能会赢那个奖。我可以赢。是的。那是一个值得追求的目标。但当然，在当时，没有人把他视为英雄。所以所有的证据都表明，大多数普通德国人对此感到非常震惊，
and it led to a big boost in support for Hitler. So this is why a good example, a really good source on the Third Reich in the early years of the war, is William L. Shira, the American correspondent, who was there the whole time, I wrote this diary. Richard Evans uses him a lot. And Shira genuinely thought the Nazis had organized this themselves, that it must have been a false flag operation because it was so productive in terms of support for the regime. And actually, Ian Kershaw says, you know, had the bomb gone off, had Hitler been killed,
这导致了对希特勒支持率的大幅提升。所以这就是为什么一个很好的例子，一个关于战争初期第三帝国非常好的来源，是美国记者威廉·L·夏伊勒，他一直都在那里，我写了这本日记。理查德·埃文斯经常引用他。夏伊勒真诚地认为纳粹是自己策划了这一切，这一定是一场虚假旗帜行动，因为它在支持政权方面非常有效。事实上，伊恩·克肖说，你知道，如果炸弹爆炸了，如果希特勒被杀了，
would the Third Reich have fallen, you know, maybe in the long run, yes. But initially, it would have led to a hardening of attitudes and a hardening of attitudes towards the allies who would have been blamed, so the war would not have ended. But they probably wouldn't have attacked in the West, or indeed in Scandinavia, perhaps. No, I'm sure they wouldn't. They'd have sort of hunkered down, maybe. Anyway, the other thing the bomb does, it completely pulls the rug out from under the plotters, the army plotters and whatnot, because they see the public reaction and they think, come on, we're not going to launch a coup now.
第三帝国会倒台吗，你知道，从长远来看，也许会。但最初，这会导致态度的强硬，以及对被指责的盟军态度的强硬，所以战争不会结束。但他们可能不会在西方，或者在斯堪的纳维亚发动攻击。不，我肯定他们不会。他们可能已经固守阵地了。无论如何，炸弹造成的另一件事是，它完全拆了阴谋者、军队阴谋者之类的台，因为他们看到了公众的反应，他们想，算了吧，我们现在不能发动政变。
I mean, the public love their furor. It would be mad to do this. So the next couple of weeks is the aftermath of the bomb, really, that's in everyone's minds. But then on the 23rd of November, Hitler tells all his senior commanders to meet him at the Reich's chancellery. It says about 200 of them, and he says to them, look, the last couple of weeks have shown me how much the German people love me and how much Providence loves me. You know, I really am walking with destiny. I've been saved from death yet again. And he says, look at all the things I've achieved.
我的意思是，公众热爱他们的元首。这样做太疯狂了。所以接下来的几周是炸弹爆炸后的余波，真的，每个人都在想这件事。但在11月23日，希特勒告诉他所有的资深指挥官在帝国总理府见他。据说有大约200人，他对他们说，看，过去几周向我展示了德国人民有多爱我，天意有多爱我。你知道，我真的是与命运同行。我又一次从死亡中获救了。他说，看看我取得的所有成就。
You know, a lot of you doubted me, the Rhineland, Austria, Czechoslovakia, Poland. But I was right. I wanted to fight and fight again, and Providence rewarded me for it. And then he goes on, he makes his, has his usual rant about living space, a racial struggle. Fighting is the law of life. In fighting, I see the fate of all creatures. If you don't want to go under, you can't avoid fighting. And he says, look, in all Germanist history, this is going back to your point, Tom,
你知道，你们很多人怀疑我，莱茵兰、奥地利、捷克斯洛伐克、波兰。但我是对的。我想战斗，再战斗，天意为此奖励了我。然后他继续说，他发表了他通常关于生存空间、种族斗争的咆哮。战斗是生命的法则。在战斗中，我看到了所有生物的命运。如果你不想灭亡，你就无法避免战斗。他说，看，在所有的日耳曼历史中，这回到了你的观点，汤姆，
about the sort of strategic sweep of German history. Hitler says our problem has always been fighting a war on two fronts. But right now, Stalin's army are knee-deep in snowdrifts, because they've got into a right mess in their war against Finland, which we'll talk about in the next episode, in the Winter War. And Hitler says, so we have a unique opportunity now to attack France and England at the most favorable and earliest moment. We'll go through Belgium and Holland.
关于德国历史的战略大扫荡。希特勒说我们的问题一直是两线作战。但现在，斯大林的军队深陷雪堆中，因为他们在对芬兰的战争中陷入了混乱，我们将在下一集讨论冬季战争。希特勒说，所以我们现在有一个独特的机会，在最有利和最早的时刻攻击法国和英国。我们将穿过比利时和荷兰。
Yeah, they're neutral. Who cares about them? You know, history will reward us for it. This is about national survival. He says, do you know who I'm like? I'm like Frederick the Great. He did love Frederick the Great, didn't he? He's always going on about Frederick the Great.
是的，他们是中立的。谁在乎他们？你知道，历史会奖励我们的。这是关于国家生存。他说，你知道我像谁吗？我像腓特烈大帝。他确实喜欢腓特烈大帝，不是吗？他总是谈论腓特烈大帝。
Great. He said, Frederick the Great in the seven years war was facing total defeat and disaster. His advisors told him to make peace, but he rolled the dice and he won. And he says, the brilliant thing for Germany, though, is that we have a secret weapon. Do you know what the secret weapon is? Would it perhaps be Adolf Hitler? Yeah, he's not a modest man. He says, Germany's secret weapon is me. As the last factor, I must in all modesty, describe myself. I'm irreplaceable. I couldn't be replaced by either a military man or a civilian. I'm convinced of my powers of intellect and of decision. Wars are always ended only by the annihilation of the opponent.
伟大。他说，腓特烈大帝在七年战争中面临彻底的失败和灾难。他的顾问告诉他要讲和，但他掷了骰子，他赢了。他说，对德国来说，辉煌的事情是，我们有一个秘密武器。你知道秘密武器是什么吗？难道是阿道夫·希特勒吗？是的，他不是一个谦虚的人。他说，德国的秘密武器就是我。作为最后一个因素，我必须非常谦虚地描述我自己。我是不可替代的。无论是军人还是平民都无法取代我。我确信我的智力和决策能力。战争总是只有通过消灭对手才能结束。
No compromises, hardness. I shall strike and not capitulate. The fate of the Reich depends on one man, on me. But I mean, he's not entirely wrong, is he? Because actually, the kind of the sense of aggression that Germany will display over the next year kind of is focused on Hitler. Without Hitler, probably those campaigns wouldn't have happened. Do you think that's fair to say?
没有妥协，只有强硬。我将出击，绝不投降。帝国的命运取决于一个人，取决于我。但我的意思是，他并不完全错误，对吧？因为事实上，德国在接下来的一年里表现出的那种侵略感确实集中在希特勒身上。没有希特勒，那些战役可能就不会发生。你认为这样说公平吗？
No, I think you're right, Tom. I think, well, Ian Kershaw, in his mighty two volumes about Adolf Hitler, has this idea that underpins the whole thing, which is working towards the Fuhrer. So this idea that basically the whole time, people in the regime have this ideal of Hitler and what Hitler would want. And they're constantly trying to, using that as their inspiration, their lodestar.
不，我认为你是对的，汤姆。我认为，嗯，伊恩·克肖在他关于阿道夫·希特勒的两卷巨著中，有一个支撑整个事情的观点，那就是“向元首靠拢”。所以这个想法基本上是，一直以来，政权中的人们都有一个希特勒的理想，以及希特勒想要什么。他们不断地试图利用这一点作为他们的灵感，他们的指路明灯。
And that has a ratcheting effect, because they assume that Hitler would always want the most radical, most decisive and reckless possible outcome. It's driving them towards ever greater radicalism. And that basically, if you took the ideal of the Fuhrer and Hitler out of that, then they might not behave in the same way. So Hitler is, to that extent, you're right, the Hitler is actually essential to the whole operation. But also, I mean, just in the context of launching war against the West in 1939. I mean, even Gering is against that. So there is a sense that Hitler is too radical even for the Nazi high command in that sense? Well, I mean, is he too radical? I mean, in a way, no,
这产生了一种棘轮效应，因为他们假设希特勒总是想要最激进、最果断和最鲁莽的可能结果。这正驱使他们走向越来越大的激进主义。基本上，如果你把元首的理想和希特勒从其中拿走，那么他们可能就不会那样做了。所以希特勒在某种程度上，你是对的，希特勒实际上对整个行动至关重要。但同时，我的意思是，仅仅在1939年对西方发动战争的背景下。我的意思是，连戈林都反对这一点。所以有一种感觉，希特勒在那种意义上对纳粹最高指挥部来说也太激进了？好吧，我的意思是，他太激进了吗？我的意思是，在某种程度上，不，
because they've crumbled, right? I mean, he has definitely pushed them into a reckless gamble that they think could end up with having disastrous consequences, but they lack the spine and the support to stop him. So that afternoon, after they've had that meeting, he summons Browich and Haldor, and he's still absolutely furious with them and says, you know, you know, defeatists, you're cowards and all this. Broucich offers to resign, and Hitler says, no, I won't accept it. You stay and do your duty. And in his biography, Ian Kershaw portrays Browich as a man totally crushed, totally
因为他们已经崩溃了，对吧？我的意思是，他确实把他们推向了一场鲁莽的赌博，他们认为这最终可能会导致灾难性的后果，但他们缺乏阻止他的骨气和支持。所以那天下午，在他们开完会后，他召见了勃劳希契和哈尔德，他仍然对他们非常愤怒，说，你知道，你们这些失败主义者，你们是懦夫等等。勃劳希契提出辞职，希特勒说，不，我不接受。你留下来履行你的职责。在他的传记中，伊恩·克肖将勃劳希契描绘成一个完全被压垮、完全
depressed, because he is about to take responsibility for an invasion in the West that deep down he opposes and he thinks will end in disaster. But with that, the last chance to stop Hitler is gone. And the obvious question, which is, why were they so weak? You know, they had the guns, they had the men, partly because they're divided. They know that the Luftwaffe and the Kriegsmarie and the Navy were much keener on Hitler than they were. But also, I think the biggest problem, he's popular. The German people like him.
沮丧的人，因为他即将为一个他内心深处反对并认为会以灾难告终的西方入侵承担责任。但随着这一点，阻止希特勒的最后机会消失了。显而易见的问题是，为什么他们如此软弱？你知道，他们有枪，他们有人，部分原因是他们分裂了。他们知道空军和海军比他们更热衷于希特勒。但我也认为最大的问题是，他很受欢迎。德国人民喜欢他。
And the chauffeurs. The chauffeurs, everybody. Ian Kershaw says, you know, Hitler was more popular than any other political leader in Europe in this period. there was a massive consensus, not everybody, of course, certainly not if you're Jewish, but among a broad swathes of society, there is this consensus that Hitler has accomplished great things, you know, that he's a good judge, that when the furor goes for something, you know, he does it. And most people, you know, especially after the bomb attack, are very much on his side. So now the course is set. The attack on the West, because of the weather,
还有司机。司机，每个人。伊恩·克肖说，你知道，希特勒在这一时期比欧洲任何其他政治领导人都更受欢迎。存在着巨大的共识，当然不是每个人，如果你是犹太人肯定不是，但在社会的大部分阶层中，存在着这种共识，即希特勒取得了伟大的成就，你知道，他是一个好的法官，当元首想要什么时，你知道，他就会去做。而且大多数人，你知道，特别是在炸弹袭击之后，非常支持他。所以现在方向已经确定了。对西方的攻击，因为天气原因，
has been postponed to the spring of 1940, but it is definitely going to happen. And in the meantime, the Navy have gone to Hitler, Grand Admiral Rader, and persuaded him to start looking at another operation, which is further north in Scandinavia, which is to safeguard shipments of iron ore. I know you love a bit of iron ore, Tom, because I noticed you mentioned it gratuitously earlier in the episode, showing off your enthusiasm for iron. Yeah, I love some iron ore stats. And the people who are interested nine or stats, I'm going to have loads in the next episode. So that's definitely something to look forward to. So as we get to the end of 1939, so many kind of threads are underway. The Nazis are thinking about the attack in the West, the thing about an attack in the north as we'll come to.
被推迟到了1940年春天，但它肯定会发生。与此同时，海军已经去找希特勒，雷德尔海军元帅，说服他开始考虑另一个行动，即在更北方的斯堪的纳维亚，以保障铁矿石的运输。我知道你喜欢铁矿石，汤姆，因为我注意到你在本集早些时候无缘无故地提到了它，炫耀你对铁的热情。是的，我喜欢一些铁矿石统计数据。对于那些对铁矿石统计数据感兴趣的人，我下一集会有很多。所以这绝对是值得期待的事情。所以当我们进入1939年底时，这么多线索正在进行中。纳粹正在考虑对西方的攻击，正如我们将要谈到的对北方的攻击。
Their euthanasia program has begun. They have started herding Jews into ghettos in Poland. The very first ghetto in the general government occupied Poland is set up in December. and Himmler and Reinhardt Heidrich are already talking about schemes for mass deportations of Jews from Poland, perhaps to some reservation somewhere, though where has not yet been determined. Because they're not yet talking about a program of mass genocide, are they? This is to come. Not yet, but in December, Hitler and Goebbels have a meeting where they explicitly say, we must eradicate what they call the Jewish danger once and for all.
他们的安乐死计划已经开始。他们已经开始把犹太人赶进波兰的隔都。波兰总督府占领区的第一个隔都在12月建立。希姆莱和莱因哈德·海德里希已经在讨论从波兰大规模驱逐犹太人的计划，也许是去某个保留地，尽管地点尚未确定。因为他们还没有谈论大规模种族灭绝的计划，对吧？这还在后面。还没有，但在12月，希特勒和戈培尔开了一个会，他们明确表示，我们必须一劳永逸地根除他们所谓的犹太危险。
So the direction of travel, you know, you can see where this is going. But of course, none of this is possible if they don't win the war in the West. As Hitler marks the new year, this is his priority. On the 15th of January, he has lunch with gerbils, and they spend a lot of time talking about the weather and how they need it, a fine spring weather to launch the offensive. And then as always, Hitler talks about history. He talks about Bismarck and Frederick the Great, his great heroes.
所以前进的方向，你知道，你可以看到这是要去哪里。但当然，如果他们不在西方赢得战争，这一切都不可能实现。当希特勒迎接新年时，这是他的首要任务。1月15日，他和戈培尔共进午餐，他们花了很多时间谈论天气，以及他们如何需要一个晴朗的春天来发动进攻。然后像往常一样，希特勒谈论历史。他谈论俾斯麦和腓特烈大帝，他伟大的英雄。
And he says, the lesson of history is that only when there is no more going back is the courage found for very big decisions. It says when the German people are up against it, in times of struggle, they always find their historical genius. If we keep going, keep rolling the dice, take the fight to the British, the prize of total victory is in sight. So people talk about learning the lessons of history, but it's not always a good thing, is it? No, not in this case. not in this case so the date is set the first blow will come in 12 weeks
他说，历史的教训是，只有在没有退路的时候，才能找到做出重大决定的勇气。他说，当德国人民陷入困境时，在斗争时期，他们总是能找到他们的历史天才。如果我们继续前进，继续掷骰子，与英国人战斗，全面胜利的奖赏就在眼前。所以人们谈论学习历史的教训，但这并不总是一件好事，不是吗？不，在这种情况下不是。在这种情况下不是，所以日期已经确定，第一次打击将在12周内到来
and it will be the invasion of Norway and Denmark then on the 10th of May Hitler will launch his greatest gamble yet the attack in the west through Holland and Belgium and the Arden forest into the heart of France an attack that will go down in history as the lightning war
那将是入侵挪威和丹麦，然后在5月10日，希特勒将发动他迄今为止最大的赌博，通过荷兰、比利时和阿登森林对西方发动攻击，直插法国心脏，这次攻击将作为闪电战载入史册
the Blitz Creek massive tension so next time in the series the Blitzkrieg will begin, although important to note the Germans didn't actually call it the Blitzkrieg. I think that was a British appellation. And after the attack on France, we'll have Dunkirk, we'll have the defeat of France, the Battle of Britain, and then Hitler's plans for Operation Barbarossa, the invasion of the Soviet Union in 1941. And members of the Restless History Club can hear all those episodes right now.
闪电战，巨大的紧张感，所以下一集系列中，闪电战将开始，尽管值得注意的是，德国人实际上并没有称之为闪电战。我认为那是英国人的称呼。在对法国的攻击之后，我们将有敦刻尔克，我们将有法国的战败，不列颠战役，然后是希特勒的巴巴罗萨行动计划，即1941年入侵苏联。Restless History Club的成员现在就可以听到所有这些剧集。
So if you want to join them, sign up at... the rest is history.com. And Tom, here's the thing. With Christmas on the way, guess what? You can give the exquisite joy of membership of the rest is history club to the history lover in your life, because you can give them a full year's membership of the rest is history club. It is the perfect gift for anybody who likes history.
所以如果你想加入他们，请在...therestis history.com注册。汤姆，事情是这样的。随着圣诞节的临近，你猜怎么着？你可以把“Rest is History”俱乐部会员资格的绝妙快乐送给你生命中热爱历史的人，因为你可以给他们一整年的“Rest is History”俱乐部会员资格。这是送给任何喜欢历史的人的完美礼物。
Actually, if people, you don't have to give us a gift, you can get it for yourself. You want to just get it for yourself. You could, couldn't you? Yeah. And here's the thing. It comes always membership of the Restis History Club with amazing benefits. But this year, this Christmas, it comes with a benefit that needs to be seen to be believed. It is an exclusive rest is history t-shirt designed in collaboration with our very own Theo Young Smith,
事实上，如果人们，你不必给我们送礼物，你可以自己买。你只想自己买。你可以，不是吗？是的。事情是这样的。Restis History俱乐部的会员资格总是带有惊人的福利。但今年，这个圣诞节，它带来了一个需要亲眼所见才能相信的福利。这是一件独家的Rest is History T恤，是与我们自己的西奥·杨·史密斯合作设计的，
who describes himself in the copy as a very stylish man. And so he is. And so will you be, if you get to wear the sensational t-shirt, which I have seen. And my goodness, it's the. ideal festive gift. So thank you, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening. We were back in the next episode with the Blitzkrieg. Happy to say. Bye-bye. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The third, Three Magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved
他在文案中形容自己是一个非常时髦的人。他确实是。如果你穿上这件我见过的轰动一时的T恤，你也会很时髦。天哪，这是理想的节日礼物。所以谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。我们将在下一集中带着闪电战回来。很高兴这么说。再见。纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予。所以罗马人在农神节分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢
wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. John, those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers. Why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history club membership? It's the discerning choice for anybody. who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper.
用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系起来。约翰，这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们对典型的圣诞早晨来说是否太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对我们的听众和观众的建议。为什么不送一些更开明的东西呢？为什么不送一份“Rest is History”俱乐部会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼篮的人来说，这是有眼光的选择。
It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows. And you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt.
这是无广告收听。你每周会得到一集额外剧集。你可以提前观看现场演出。你还可以获得独家的深度系列。此外，今年特别礼品版的Restis History俱乐部会员资格还附带一件轰动一时的独家T恤。
It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the cool people in your neighbourhood. If such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to the rest is history.com and click on gifts. That is the restishistory.com and please click on gifts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它会让你成为所有邻居和社区里所有酷人的羡慕对象。如果这样的人存在，他们会钦佩你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestis history.com并点击礼物。那是therestis history.com，请点击礼物。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。